ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BECKER FORGES BRADFORD COME BY
ADAM CORTEZ HE DALLIED DODD
AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED FLAVOR
THE MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MIN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT SHOW A BOGO
PAN FORTUNE TINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG QUAKE
OWSKI WINNER WELL. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER TODAY BY SENATOR STERN.
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF-ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR HER TADO
SINISTER. MERCIFUL AND GRACIOUS
GOD AS THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PERSISTS AND THE
NATURAL DISASTERS OF FIRE AND
FLOOD CONTINUED TO IMPACT THE
LIVES OF SO MANY WE ASK YOU TO
BE PRESENT WITH US IN OUR GRIEF
GRIEF FOR THOSE WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES AND PROPERTY GRIEF
FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS FIRE
FIGHTERS ANOTHER ESSENTIAL
WORKERS RISKING THEIR LIVES TO
PROTECT US GRIEF FOR ALL WE
HAVE TO LET GO OF AS WE STRIVE
TO ADJUST TO A NEW KIND OF
NORMAL LOVING GOD. HELP US TO
REACH BENEATH OUR GRIEF TO
DISCOVER THE CREATIVE FORCE OF
LIFE BURIED BENEATH OUR HEAVY
HEARTS MAY WE FIND HOPE THAT
CREATIVE SPIRIT TO HELP US
BUILD THE NEW FROM THE ASHES OF
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION MAYBE
EXPERIENCE HEALING AND
RESTORATION AS WE GIVE THE BEST
OF OURSELVES FOR OUR FELLOW
HUMANS. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME I'M IN. COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG AT THE END. ISRAEL
ALL. MEMBERS WE ARE PRETTY FULL
AGENDA TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH THE PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR WE.
MEMBERS WERE
HAD PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
THIS IS THE TIME IN OUR SESSION
THAT WILL RECOGNIZE OUR SENATE
FOLLOWS AND WILL OPEN THEIR
PROCESS SO FAR FOURTEEN OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM REMARKS ON
THE PROGRAM. CENTER PROJECT MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO TAKE A
MINUTE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD
WORK AND COMMITMENT OF OUR
SENATE FELLOWS. ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THE
SENATE FELLOWS PROGRAM OPENS
THE DOORS OF THE STATE CAPITOL
TO EIGHTEEN INDIVIDUALS GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN
OUR TEAMS FULL TIME FOR ELEVEN
MONTHS WHILE ALSO EARNING
GRADUATE CREDIT AS A RESULT OF
THEIR OUTSTANDING SERVICE ALL
SENATE FELLOWS ARE WELL
EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE VALUABLE
LEADERSHIP AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR REGIONAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND TO
PROFESSIONAL BUSINESS AND
COMMUNITY ENDEAVORS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND OUR NATION'S
THIS CLASS OF FELLOWS HAS TRULY
HAD TO ADAPT TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF OUR DAY AND I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUES
WHEN ISAY THAT WORK THEY DO
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IS
INVALUABLE THE FELLOWS ARE A
VITAL PART OF OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY. THIS YEAR ALONE THEY
WORKED ON OVER FIFTY BILLS
SIXTEEN RESOLUTIONS AND STAFFED
COUNTLESS COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
WE ARE PROUD TO HAVE SUCH
CAPABLE FUTURE LEADERS AMONG
US. IN FACT. LET ME TAKE A
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE.
AND SAY LISA CHEN IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE
MY CHIEF OF STAFF NICK HARTMAN
OUR SENATE FELLOW ALUMNI. I
KNOW THAT YOU ALL HAVE STORIES
AS WELL YOU ARE OUTGOING
FELLOWS I SAY THIS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND
YOUR DEDICATION TO PUBLIC
SERVICE ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
MOST DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING
DAYS. YOUR EFFORTS HAVE HELPED
MAKE CALIFORNIA A BETTER PLACE
FOR US ALL. MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU FOR LET ME OPEN UP I KNOW
THERE'S A WHOLE PROGRAM AND I
APPRECIATE THE FEW MINUTES TO
GIVE THOSE OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU RUN A BROAD TERM. NOW
WILL PROCEED WITH OUR FIRST
FULL RECOGNITION. SPERM BANK
CLERK PLEASE READ
CONGRATULATIONS TO JULIE L.
BAKER FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA. CHILE GRADUATED
FROM HOWARD UNIVERSITY EARNING
A BA IN ECONOMICS AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE GIULIO WAS PLACED IN
THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. SIX HUNDRED MAGOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE TO SAY
THAT WE ARE EXTREMELY LUCKY AND-GRATEFUL TO HAVE JULIE L. AS A
FELLOW IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT. IF
YOU DON'T KNOW JULIE- HE'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY YOUNG MAN HE
BRINGS PASSION HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION. EVERY THING HE DOES
HE'S RIGHT HERE FOR MORE IN
JAIL. AND HE HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE ASSET TO THE TEAM AS
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST BILL LOADS IN THE
SENATE MANY ARE INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED AND GIULIO DOVE
HEADFIRST IN SOME COMPLICATED
SUBJECTS SUCH AS COMPLEX SALES
TAX OBLIGATIONS FOR
PAWNBROKERS. CITIES EXITING
SERVICES OUTSIDE THEIR
BOUNDARIES AND SPHERES OF
INFLUENCE PENALTIES TO PUNISH
WATER THEFT AND PARK DISTRICT
NEWTON'S ABATEMENT. AS
CHALLENGING AS THESE BILLS WERE
DELIAL DISTINGUISH HIMSELF HE
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF WITH HIS
WORK ON LEGISLATION FOCUSING IN
ON RULES FOR POLICE AND
SHERIFF'S USE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT ALSO AMONG MANY
OTHERS WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO
JULIE- JOINING US THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU AGAIN JULIE OVER ALL
THE HARD WORK AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE GOLDEN
STATE THANK YOU MISTER BAKER
FOR YOUR SERVICES STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE NEXT UP AND CLARK
CONGRATULATIONS TO SYMPHONY
BARBIE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA SYMPHONY GRADUATED
FROM CINEMA CINEMA STATE
UNIVERSITY EARNING A BA IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE SYMPHONY WAS
PLACED IN SENATOR SKINNER'S
OFFICE. SENATOR CALM WATER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I AM
CERTAINLY NOT SENATOR SKINNER
BUT I AM HERE ON HER BEHALF TO
PRESENT THE RESOLUTION TO HER
FELLOW MISS STEPHANIE BARBIE.
THIS BARBIE HAS BEEN THE LEAD
STAFF FOR THE CALIFORNIA MOM
THE BEST ACT SENATE BILL SIXTY
FIVE OF WHICH I AM A PROUD CO
AUTHOR MISS BARBIE WORKS
CLOSELY WITH A LARGE STATEWIDE
AND NATIONAL COALITION LED BY
BLACK WOMEN TO IMPROVE MATERNAL
HEALTH IN BIRTHING JUSTICE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. ESPECIALLY
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR THIS BARBIE
SHOULD BE ALSO PROUD OF THE
SEVERAL MONITORS PROVISIONS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDING MEDICARE AL DOULA
SERVICES WHO THE BASIC NEEDS
ASSISTANCE AND POST NATAL MEDIC
COW SERVICES AND WE KNOW SHE
AND THE MOM THE BUS ACTIVISTS
ARE ANXIOUSLY AWAITING A
DECISION IN THE BILL FROM THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE LATER THIS WEEK DONE
DONE A NATIVE OF CALIFORNIA A
FORMER PANETTA COMPRESSIONAL
INTERN AND GRADUATE OF CINEMA
STATE UNIVERSITY AFTER THE
FELLOWSHIP IS BARBIE PLANS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IN THE CAPITOL
COMMUNITY ON PUBLIC POLICY
PERTAINING TO ISSUES OF BLACK
HEALTH AND WEALTH AND WOMEN'S
BIRTHING AND REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE. ISSUES THANK YOU THANK
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISS
PARLEY LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR HER WORK. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. MADAM
READING CLERK CONGRATULATIONS
TO LESLIE BRIZUELA FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA LESLIE
GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS EARNING
A BA AND POLITICAL SCIENCE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND PUBLIC
SERVICE LESLIE WAS PLACED IN
SENATOR LAYERS OFFICE SINNER
LED TO FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND LET ME SAY
FIRST THAT THE WEEK AFTER THE
ELECTION THEY EXTENDED THE
DEADLINE FOR THE NEWLY ELECTED
MEMBERS AND I INTERVIEWED
PERSONALLY ELEVEN OF THESE
FELLOWS CANDIDATES AND I CAN
JUST SAY WITH CERTAINTY THAT
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE HIGH CALIBER
OF PEOPLE. END OF THAT WE ARE
HONORING TODAY. I WOULD LIKE TO
HONOR AND RECOGNIZE LESLIE
BELTRAN BRIZUELA FOR THEIR
OUTSTANDING WORK SHE'S DONE IN
MY OFFICE THIS YEAR SHE'S FROM
THE BAY AREA SHE'S THE ELDEST
OF THREE CHILDREN SHE IS A
CHILD OF IMMIGRANTS AND SHE'S A
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT WHO GRADUATED FROM UC
DAVIS LESLIE DURING HER TIME IN
MY OFFICE. HAS WORKED ON SIX
BILLS ONE OF WHICH HAS ALREADY
BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW. AND STAFF
MEET ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WHICH WAS NO EASY
ASSIGNMENT. IN OUR TIME OUTSIDE
OF MY OFFICE SHE SERVES AS AN
ELECTED BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATIN ACTS CAPITAL
ASSOCIATION. AS FELLOWS
REPRESENTATIVE AND PROGRAM
COORDINATOR. SHE ORGANIZED AND
RAN A FOUR WEEK LONG SUMMER
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
PROVIDED ALL STUDENTS WITH A
SCHOLARSHIP AND WORK WITH
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY OFFICES TO
TEACH STUDENTS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AS IF ALL
OF THAT ISN'T ENOUGH SHE ALSO
RUNS A SMALL BUSINESS FROM HER
HOME. WHERE SHE MAKES HANDMADE
FUNCTIONAL AND DECORATIVE
CERAMICS. SHE HAS PROMISED
CURRENT HIGHER OFFICE SOME OF
THESE CERAMIC CREATIONS WITHIN
THE GIFT LIMITS OF WHICH I WILL
HOLD HER TO. SERVE HER
PERSONALITY POSITIVE ATTITUDE
AND STRON WORK ETHIC I WORK
ETHIC HAS MADE HER A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING HER PURSUE HER GOALS
IN PUBLIC SERVICE WITH GREAT
SUCCESS I'M PROUD TO PARTNER
LESLIE BRISTLING THANK YOU
SENATOR LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE HIS FIRST CHOICE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE WRANGLER
ANNEX HELLO CONGRATULATIONS TO
KATIE COMER FROM LINCOLN
CALIFORNIA HE GRADUATED FROM
WILLIAM JESSUP UNIVERSITY
EARNING A BA IN PUBLIC POLICY
KATIE WAS PLACED IN THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN POLICY OFFICE. WHAT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT OUR MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE OUR SENATE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS FELLOW KATIE
KAMMERER. KATIE WAS ASSIGNED TO
THE CAUCUS- POLICY OFFICE AND I
THOUGH I HAVE NOT WORKED WITH
HER DIRECTLY AT HER SHE'S HAD A
VERY BUSY AND SUCCESSFUL YEAR-
DURING HER TIME THERE SHE IS
ANALYSED NINETY ONE BILLS. FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE WHICH AS WE ALL KNOW
IT'S A HEAVY LIFT- LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT IN
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE AND SHE'S
ALSO WORKED ON A LOT OF
REQUESTS FOR THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
JUST PRIOR TO ACCEPTING THE
FELLOWSHIP FELLOWSHIP SHE GOT
MARRIED SO SHE'S BEEN JUGGLING
THE FELLOWSHIP. A NEW MARRIAGE
AND SHE'S NOW WEEKS AWAY FROM
COMPLETING HER MBA FROM WILLIAM
JESSUP UNIVERSITY'S SHE SAID
QUITE AN INCREDIBLE YEAR. I
WISH WE WERE ALL THAT-
PRODUCTIVE DURING COATED PATCHY
RECENTLY LAUNCHED A NONPROFIT
CALLED A PARK WHICH IS AN
ADOPTION RESOURCE CENTER IN
PLASTER COUNTY FOR PARENTS
ADOPTEES AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED BY ADOPTION. KATIE IS
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT OF A
DIFFERENT NONPROFIT CALLED
FLAME WHICH IS A WIN A WOMAN'S
MENTORSHIP ORGANIZATION IN FACT
HER SECOND CLASS AMENITIES ARE
STARTING NEXT WEEK. SHE IS THE
PROUD OWNER OF A MINIATURE
GERMAN SHEPHERD NAMED CHARLIE
WHOM SHE DESCRIBES AS SUPER
CUTE HE OBVIOUSLY IS NOT SEEN
MY TWO DOGS BECAUSE SHE WOULD
BE ABLE TO SAY THAT BUT- SHE'S
DOESN'T KNOW THAT SO IT'S OKAY.
KATIE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO OUR CAUCUS AND
YOU ARE DEFINITELY A CREDIT- TO
NOT ONLY NOT ONLY FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM BUT THE ENTIRE CAUCUS
AND WITH THAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE GREAT THING SHE DO
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR WORK
CONGRATULATIONS THIS CAMERA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
READING CLERK OR NEXT HELLO
CONGRATULATIONS TO NEW ****
RYPIEN FROM GLAND GLENDALE
CALIFORNIA NEED A GRADUATED
FROM LILLE UNIVERSITY EARNING A
BA IN POLITICAL SCIENCE NINI
WAS PLACED IN A SENATOR
WIENER'S OFFICE SENATOR WIENER
I THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- WE
WERE VERY VERY LUCKY TO HAVE A
NEW NAME IN OUR OFFICE- THIS
YEAR- AS YOU HEARD SHE COMES
FROM GLENDALE FROM- CENTER
PRETTINESS BY DISTRICT-
GRADUATED FROM YALE WITH A
LOCAL SCIENCE DEGREE SHE IS
EXTREMELY TALENTED PERSON A
GREAT PHOTOGRAPHER. WE LEARNED
THAT SHE HAS A GREEN THUMB
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED IN
OUR OFFICE GIVEN OUR HISTORY OF
KILLING PERFECTLY GOOD PLANTS
AND SO DOES THAT OF SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
SHE MAKES HOMEMADE CANDLES
WHICH WAS WONDERFUL AND I KNOW
MY OTHER STUFF REALLY ENJOYED-
THAT TIME SHE ALSO WAS GOING TO
STEP IN ON SOME VERY DIFFICULT
BILLS ARE YOU MAY RECALL
CALLING SET EARLY IN THE YEAR
WE- WE I LAUNCH AN ABORTED
EFFORT LEGISLATION TO UNDER
BAND THEY'RE HIDING. IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE WERE SOME
PEOPLE WHO HAD OPINIONS ABOUT
THAT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION AND I KNEW THERE WAS
A STAFFING THAT BILL AND
HANDLED IT WITH ABSOLUTE GRACE-
AS A BRAND NEW FELLOWS SO-
THAT- THAT WOULD HAVE TESTED
EVEN THE MOST EXPERIENCED ON
THE SET OF A- SHE- STAFFED US
ON OUR OUTDOOR DINING BILL THIS
YEAR- BUILD TO- TO BAN-
TOXICITY TESTING ON DOGS AND
CATS WHICH HAS BEEN A-
CONTROVERSIAL. BILL AND OF
COURSE SHE DIED SASS ME ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE AND FOR
ANYONE WHO KNOWS THAT COMMITTEE
IT'S A RAMBUNCTIOUS COMMITTEE
DUE TO THE CHAIR- BUT SHE ALSO
HANDLES IT WITH ABSOLUTE GRACE-
SO I NEED IT THANK YOU. FOR
BEING A GREAT PART OF OUR TEAM.
THIS YEAR THANK YOU SENATOR
WINNER THAT SIX. TO ME
CARIBBEAN. A- MINUTE PLUG OR
NEXT FALL CONGRATULATIONS TO
ADRIANA GOMEZ FROM WATSONVILLE
CALIFORNIA COUNTRY ON A
GRADUATED FROM UC SANTA BARBARA
EARNING A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE ADRIANA WAS PLACED IN
SENATOR MCGUIRE'S OFFICE
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT NIGERIANEYE IS SO
GOOD AT WHAT SHE DOES BECAUSE
IT'S PERSONAL SHE'S THE PROUD
DAUGHTER OF HARD WORKING
IMMIGRANTS MARIA AND JOSE OUR
COMMUNITY IN EXPERIENCES
GROWING UP INSPIRED HER TO
BECOME THE FIRST IN OUR FAMILY
TO GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. AND
OUT OF THERE TO PURSUE A CAREER
IN PUBLIC POLICY TO BREAK DOWN
THE INJUSTICES THAT EXIST IN
OUR SOCIETY AND SHE'S PLAYED AN
INTEGRAL ROLE IN SERVING THE
NORTH COAST THIS YEAR. SHE HAS
CONSISTENTLY CONSISTENTLY RISEN
TO THE OCCASION WITH A SMILE ON
HER FACE THE BETTER SERVE THE
RESIDENTS OF THE NORTH COAST
DURING THE CHALLENGES OF THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN THE
PANDEMIC. SHE'S WORKED ON FIVE
DIFFERENT BILLS FOR OFFICE
STAFF THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WORKED ON PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES
FOR THE JOINT FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE COMMITTEE ALL TO BE
ABLE TO BETTER THE INDUSTRY OF
THE GOLDEN STATE'S FISHERMEN
AND WOMEN. AND I GOTTA TELL YOU
SHE HASN'T FLOUNDERED ON THAT
ASSIGNMENT- UNDER JANA IS
PERSEVERANCE. ADRIANA IS KIND
AND SHE IS DRIVEN AND WE LOVE
HAVING HER ON THE TEAM DESPITE
THE FACT THAT SHE LOVES
PINEAPPLE ON HER PIZZA. FINALLY
OUR OFFICE IN THE GOLDEN STATE
MR PRESIDENT. WE'RE STRONGER.
BECAUSE OF HER WORK
CONGRADULATIONS GOMEZ AND WE
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT COMES
NEXT IN YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THANKS TO CINNABAR LET'S
CONGRATULATE MS GOMEZ THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE A
READING CLERK CONGRATULATIONS
TO CONGRATULATIONS TO REVIEW
GONZALEZ PADA FROM PICO RIVERA
CALIFORNIA RUBY GRADUATED FROM
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY
EARNING A BA AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE RUBY WAS PLACED IN
SENATOR LEMONS OFFICE SENATOR
LAMAR. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ENJOYEDWORKING WITH RUBY
GONZALEZ BARBARA AND ARE SO
THANKFUL SHE WAS PLACED IN OUR
OFFICE HER GOALS COMING INTO
THE FELLOWSHIP WERE TO LEARN
HOW TO ANALYZE LEGISLATION I
UNDERSTAND THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND BECOME AN EXPERT IN AN
ISSUE AREA. EVEN THOUGH THIS
LEGISLATIVE YEAR CONTINUE TO
DEVIATE FROM THE NORMAL PROCESS
RUBY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DIVE INTO A VARIETY OF ISSUES
DURING THE FELLOWSHIP REVIEW IS
KEY STAFF ON FOUR BILLS A
RESOLUTION AND THE STAFF HEALTH
COMMITTEE WHICH WE KNOW. IS NO
SMALL TASK SHE WORKED ON BILLS
TO HELP CANCER PATIENTS GET
FASTER TREATMENT AND TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CONSUMERS HAVE
INFORMATIONS ABOUT THEIR
DEDUCTIBLES. RUBY ALSO TAUGHT
US AND TAUGHT THE WHOLE OFFICE
THE IMPORTANCE OF READING UNTIL
THE END OF AN EMAIL BECAUSE IF
YOU DID. YOU WOULD FIND THAT
SHE WOULD HAVE THE BEST TEAM TO
GET US THROUGH THE END OF THE
WEEK THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR DEDICATION AND SERVICE TO
THE CONSTITUENTS OF THE
NINETEEN SENATE DISTRICT. YOUR
SENSE OF HUMOR LOVE FOR FOOD
AND COLLABORATIVE STYLE FIT
RIGHT IN WITH TEAM LEE MON
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RAMON CONGRATULATIONS MR
GONZALEZ PRODUCT FOR YOUR
SERVICE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.%
BEEN READING CLERK NEXT FELLOW
CONGRATULATIONS TO BRIXTON LANE
FROM SANGER CALIFORNIA BRIXTON
GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS EARNING
A BA IN INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS
BRIXTON WAS PLACED IN SENATOR
JONES OFFICE SENATOR JONES
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES- IT IS AN HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE BRICKS IN THIS
AFTERNOON BRIXEN IS PERSONABLE
TALENTED AND VERY POLITE AND
GRACIOUS AS PEOPLE ARE VISITING
THE FEW PEOPLE THAT I VISITED
THE OFFICE- THIS YEAR'S HE
GREETS THEM HE'S AN OUTSTANDING
JOB IN THE SENATE AND FOR TEAM
JONES IS- PAST CHALLENGING YEAR
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN VERY EAGER-
WHEN THE FELLOWS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO COME INTO THE CAPITAL TO BE
ONE OF THE FIRST ONES TO SHOW
UP. AND WORK HARD HERE IN THE
CAPITAL THEN OF COURSE WE'RE
CARD FROM HOME AS WELL- WHEN
WE'RE WORKING REMOTELY THESE-
STAFFS- MYSLF ON A PROBST AND
HUMAN SERVICES HE HAS CARRIED
SEVERAL OF MY BILLS INCLUDING
SB FOUR HUNDRED. DEALING WITH
HOMELESS STUDENTS SP FIVE FORTY
NINE. MAKING SOCIAL WORKERS
ESSENTIAL AND SP FIVE SEVENTY
EIGHT THE LPS CONSERVATORSHIP-
DISCLOSURE- BILLS AND- HE'S
WORKED VERY HARD ON THOSE IN A
COUPLE OF OTHERS. AND HE'S GOT
A GREAT FUTURE AHEAD OF THEM IN
FACT HE'S ONLY GOT A JOB LINED
UP UNFORTUNATELY. WITH A MUCH
LESS PRESTIGE IS- ORGANIZATION
THAN OURSELVES HE'S GOING TO
THE U. S. CONGRESS- BUT WE'RE
HOPING THAT HE CAN SLING SHOT
BACK INTO THE STATE SENATE-
QUICKLY AND- REGAIN THE
PRESTIGE OF WORKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TIM HAVING A
SIX X. SUCCESSFUL TIME THERE
WE'RE GONNA MISS HIM HE HAS
BEEN AN INTEGRAL PART OF OUR
OFFICE AND I JUST WANNA SAY
BRIXTON THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK WE
APPRECIATE IT AND WE WILL MISS
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES CONGRATULATIONS
TO MR LANG THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE I'M READING CLERK
CONGRATULATIONS TO ILLICITLY
FROM FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA
ALYSSA GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS
EARNING A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND COMMUNICATION
STUDIES ALYSSA WAS PLACED AND
SENATOR MEN'S OFFICE.
DETERMINED IT'S MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO RECOGNIZE OUR
FELLOW ILLICITLY TODAY SHE'S A
LOCAL PRODUCT A RESIDENT OF
FAIRFIELD A SAC STATE AND UC
DAVIS GRAD AND SHE'S BEEN A
TRULY INVALUABLE MEMBER OF OUR
TEAM. HAVE YOU INTERACTED WITH
ALYSSA YOU MAY BE SURPRISED TO
LEARN THAT SHE'S IN A
FELLOWSHIP HERE BECAUSE SHE
WORKS LIKE A SEASONED CAPITAL
PRO. HE'S WORKED ON SOME OF OUR
TOUGHEST BILLS AND POLICY
ISSUES- IN OFFICE INCLUDING
SOME OF THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL
ONES I GOT TO KNOW HER QUITE
WELL BACK IN JANUARY WHEN EVERY
WEEK WE'RE MEETING ONCE OR
TWICE A WEEK AS PART OF THE
BUDGET SUB ONE HEARINGS THAT
SHE WAS STAFFING. I SHE TOOK ON
SOME OF OUR HARDEST TASKS AND
SHE DID IT WITH APLOMB AND WITH
AN INCREDIBLY AND RELENTLESSLY
POSITIVE ATTITUDE. NOT ONLY IS
ALYSSA TALENTED INTELLIGENT
HARD WORKING BUT SHE HAS
INCREDIBLE POISE I ALSO JUST
WANT TO MENTION ONE THING SHE
WORKED ON THAT I WAS SAD NEVER
SAW THE LIGHT OF DAY BUT IT WAS
A RESOLUTION TO TRY TO
RECOGNIZE SPAM AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF SPAM SPAM IS TO
BE AN ALLY- WHEN THAT WAS
REJECTED FOR PROCEDURAL
REASONS- ALYSSA. I TOOK IT ON
THE CHIN BUT KEPT PLUGGING
AHEAD I HAVING OUR STAFF OUR
OFFICE SHE WAS ALSO THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES LIAISON
FROM OUR OFFICE AND I'VE NO
DOUBT THIS WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
THE EXCEPTIONAL LEGACY OF API
STAFF THAT HAVE WORKED IN THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. AND GONE ON
TO BRIGHT THINGS WALLER SAID
THE LYSIS FELLOWSHIP IS
CUMMINGTON AND WE'RE SO EXCITED
FOR WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR
AND I KNOW I SPEAK FOR OUR
ENTIRE OFFICE WHEN I SAY IT'S
BEEN AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO SENATE DISTRICT.
THIRTY SEVEN AND TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WAS THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN CONGRATULATIONS
MISLI FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE THANK
YOU MEMORY ENGLERT
CONGRATULATIONS TO JOE
LIEBERMAN FROM CAL FROM IRVINE
CALIFORNIA JODY GRADUATED FROM
UCLA EARNING A BA IN ECONOMICS
JODY WAS PLACED IN SENATOR
BATES OFFICE SENATOR IDGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
CERTAINLY MY HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
JUDY LIEBERMAN OF THE THIRTY
SIX SENATE DISTRICT HAS BEEN SO
THANKFUL THEY HAVE JUDY SERVICE
THE SENATE FELLOW IN OUR OFFICE
THIS YEAR HAS MENTIONED SHE'S A
UCLA GRADUATE WITH A DEGREE IN
ECONOMICS AND YOU DON'T KNOW
THAT'S A REAL TOUGH FROM. A
MAJOR SEVEN ORANGE COUNTY
RESIDENT SHE HAS BEEN A GREAT
FEAR BECAUSE SHE HAS A HOME
GROWN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DISTRICT ISSUES THAT HAVE
PLAGUED OUR PARTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY THIS YEAR GROWTH OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ISSUE AND
MOST ARE DIFFICULT A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ISSUE AMONG SOME OF OUR
VERY VERY YOUNG I JUNIOR HIGH
AND HIGH SCHOOL KIDS VERY
DIFFICULT YEAR WITH STAFFING
LET LIMITATIONS SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS AND ALL
THE OTHER CODE RELATED
CHALLENGES JODY HAS STEPPED UP
AT EVERY TURN. HAS BEEN A KEY
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE EFFORTS OF
OUR OFFICE IN THE SENATE AS A
WHOLE SHE STOPPED OF OUR
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS IN
WHAT SHE DID FOR ME WAS THE
SUNSET REVIEWS WITH THE MANY
MANY ISSUES THAT WE HAD TO LOOK
AT SHE HAD THOSE ARE SUMMARIZED
IN A VERY SUCCINCT WAY FOR ME
TO BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH YOU
KNOW MOUNTS AND MOUNTS OF
INFORMATION AND SHE ALWAYS HAD
A WAY TO ANSWER MY QUESTIONS-
IF I HAPPEN TO MISS A
PARTICULAR PART OF THAT. BUT
THEN UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY
SHE'S VERY BRIGHT VERY HARD
WORKING AND WILLING TO TAKE ON
ANY CHALLENGE THAT WE PRESENTED
HER I KNOW THERE ARE GREAT
THINGS TO COME FOR HER AND WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AND IT WAS A
GREAT PLEASURE AND HONOR TO
HAVE YOU IN OUR OFFICE JODY
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES. CONGRADULATIONS
TO MISS LIEBERMAN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR AND I'M READING CLERK
CONGRATULATIONS TO ELMER LIZ RT
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
ELMER GRADUATED FROM UCLA
EARNING A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE ELMER WAS PLACED IN
SENATOR WESSELS OFFICE IN A WAY
SO THANK YOU I MISS PRESIDENT
SENATORS ARE YOU FIRST OF ALL I
JUST WANT TO CONGRATULATE ALL
THE FELLOWS AND THIS WONDERFUL
PROGRAM AND WE ARE JUST SO
HONORED AND PLEASED TO HAVE
ELEMENT SRT IS PART OF OUR TEAM
HE'S BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
VALUABLE ASSET YOUR CAT CAPITAL
OFFICE WORKING IN AREAS OF
ENERGY LABOR IN THE HOUSE AND
HE'S BEEN. WORKING ON OUR OUR
STOP THE BLEED BILL WHICH HAS
BEEN GOING VERY WELL UNDER HIS
HIS DIRECTION SO WE HAVE BEEN
VERY PLEASED WITH HIS WORK IN
THE OFF OFFICE WHEN HE WAS A
CHILD. HE AND HIS FAMILY
MIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
FROM THEIR HOME IN MEXICO TO
PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM. WELL
IN THIS COUNTRY AS A DACA
STUDENT. ELMER THRIVED AND
SERVED AS A PHENOMENAL
REPRESENTED OR MORE OF AN
AMBASSADOR. FOR THE DACA
PROGRAM. AS A OF SACRAMENTO'S
CHRISTIAN BROTHERS HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE AS A SALUTED AFTER
GRAD HIGH THE OWNER OF A MY ALL
MY MATER OF COURSE THE NO ONE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN THE
COUNTRY AND SOON TO BE THE
NUMBER ONE UNIVERSITY IN THE
pCONGRATULATE ALL THE UCLA
GRADUATES WHICH WE ARE VERY
WELL REPRESENTED IN THIS CLASS-
AGAIN A LOT OF- BRUIN PRIDE
GOES OUT TO. ALL THE GRADUATES
AND OF COURSE THEY'RE SERVING
OUR SENATE VERY WELL HE
GRADUATED FROM UCLA WITH A
BACHELOR OF ARTS IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE WITH A MINOR MINOR.
CHICANA STUDIES AND MAC MAGNA
**** LAUDE DISTINCTION. IN
ADDITION TO HIS ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE ELMER IS A VERY
TALENTED SOCCER PLAYER- OF
COURSE HE'S BEEN NICE TO US IN
THE PRACTICES ONLYRUNNING
CIRCLES AROUND US TWO OR THREE
TIMES AS- OPPOSED TO FIVE OR
SIX THAT HE CAN. EASILY DO IS A
VERY TALENTED PLAYER HE IN FACT
HE SHOULD BE PLAYING
PROFESSIONAL SOCCER. HE HOPES
TO CONTINUE HIS CAREER IN
PUBLIC POLICY AND INSPIRES TO
ATTEND LAW SCHOOL. IN THE
FUTURE AND I JUST WANNA THANK.
THE SENATE FOR PUTTING HIM INOUR OFFICE WERE VERY. HONORED
AND VERY GRATEFUL AND AGAIN I
WANNA. CONGRATULATE ALMER ELMER
FOR. BEING PART OF THIS PROGRAM
AND OF COURSE THANK HIM FOR ALL
HIS FINE WORK- TO OUR OFFICE
AND TO THE SENATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHAT SHOW AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO MR LIVES
ALREADY THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
SERVICE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE MAN CLERK CONGRATULATE
TO ALL OF SANDRA MAGNUS GO FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA ALL THE
SANDRA'S GRADUATED FROM CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO EARNING A
BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE IN
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION
ALEXANDER WAS PLACED AND
SENATOR OCHO ABODES OFFICE
SOONER TO A BOOK I HAVE BEEN SO
PLEASED TO HAVE A LASAGNA IN
OUR OFFICE THIS YEAR SHE'S BEEN
AN ABSOLUTE DELIGHT SHE BRINGS
A 1000% ENERGY EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AND SHE CONSTANTLY AMAZES
ME WITH HER DUE DILIGENCE AND
THOUGHTFUL NATURE SHE HAS TO
HAVE TWO COMMITTEES FOR US
LABOR AND HOUSING BOTH
COMMITTEES THAT ARE CERTAINLY
NOT EASY ONES. HE ALSO STABBED
SEVERAL BILLS AND RESOLUTIONS
SHEPHERDING THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY IN HER WORDS HER
FAVORITE ASPECT OF THIS
FELLOWSHIP WITH DIVING INTO THE
LEGISLATION AND PROVIDING
INFORMATIVE BRIEFINGS. WELL GET
READY ALESSANDRA BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'LL BE DOING FOR THE
YEARS TO COME IT HAS BEEN AN
EXCITING FIRST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR BOTH OF US. I
LOVE LEARNING ALONGSIDE HER
THANK YOU FOR BEING A GREAT
STAFFER THANK YOU ALSO TO HER
PARENTS WHO ARE HERE IN THE
GALLERY TODAY FOR RAISING SUCH
AS FINE AND RESPECTFUL YOUNG
LADY. THANK YOU SENATOR-
TROUBLED. IN CONGRADULATIONS TO
MIXMAG. NASCO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE MADAM READING
CLERK. CONGRATULATIONS TO DEANA
MILLER FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA DEANA GRADUATED FROM
UC SANTA CRUZ EARNING A BA IN
PSYCHOLOGY DIONNE I WAS PLACED
IN SENATOR KABBADI AUTOS OFFICE
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE SENATE FELLOWS
PROGRAM FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
DO TO PLACE SUCH INCREDIBLE
MINDS IN OUR OFFICE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO A CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM
COLLEAGUES I'S AN HONOR TO
RISE TODAY IN SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT A PRIVILEGE IT IS THE BAND
TO WELCOME DEANNA MILLER INTO
MY OFFICE. SINCE THE DAY THAT
SHE JOINED THE TEAM SHE'S SHOWN
AN EAGERNESS FOR PUBLIC
SERVICE. AND EXCITEMENT TO
LEARN AND HAS. ALWAYS HAD A
POSITIVE ATTITUDE WITH A SMILE
ON HER FACE WHENEVER I COME IN
THE OFFICE. DESPITE WHAT WE
CALL AN ABNORMAL HERE SHE HAS
EXCELLED IN HER ROLE AND WAS IT
A WELCOME ADDITION TO THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. DURING THE
TIME THAT SHE WORKED IN MY
OFFICE DEANNA MILLER TOOK ON A
VARIETY OF PROJECTS. SHOP
PROVIDES SUPPORT FOR ME ON
HOUSING HIGHER EDUCATION HUMAN
SERVICES MILITARY AND VETS
AFFAIRS AND INSURANCE HE TOOK.
A CONSTITUENT CALLS. AND SHE
DID AN EXCELLENT JOB ESPECIALLY
DURING THESE DIFFICULT TIMES
WITH CRANKY CALLERS IF YOU'VE-
EVER. HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER CALL YOU KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES IT'S REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE IN
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS. BY THE
TIME THEY CALL OUR OFFICE. HER
ENERGY AND CAN DO ATTITUDE
MEANT THAT SHE WAS READY TO HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING AS A NEW
STAFFER WHERE WHERE SHE QUICKLY
LEARNED THE FUNDAMENTALS
NECESSARY TO STAFF THREE BILLS.
AND THREE RESOLUTIONS JUST THIS
YEAR. ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE
OFFICE I WANT TO THANK DANNA
MILLER FOR ALL OF OUR WORK AND
SERVICE TO THE SENATE DISTRICT
TWELVE. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HER CONTINUED GROWTH AND KNOW
THAT SHE WILL DO GREAT THINGS
THANK YOU IT WAS AN HONOR TO
PRESENT THIS RESOLUTION TODAY
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO MISS MILLER
THANK YOU. AS WELL FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE MADAM READING CLERK
CONGRATULATIONS TO DAVE ON
THOMAS FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA EVEN GRADUATED FROM
UC SANTA CRUZ EARNING A BA IN
HISTORY DAVID WAS PLACED IN
SENATOR PANS OFFICE SENATOR VAN
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I TOO
WANT TO FIRST OF ALL
CONGRATULATE ALL OF THE SENATE
FELLOWS IN THIS A CHALLENGING
YEAR BUT OPE THAT EVERYONE HAD
A CHANCE TO LEARN A LOT ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. I'M
REALLY THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE VON THOMAS
WHO'S A SACRAMENTO NATIVE HE-
GREW UP. IN OAK PARK A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT HE THAT I'M NOT QUITE
OLD ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN HIS
PEDIATRICIAN SINCE THAT'S WHERE
I USED TO PRACTICE- THOSE
REALLY THRILLED TO HAVE HIM IN
MY OFFICE. HE WORKED HARD
STAFFING BOTH THE ME FOR THE
EDUCATION AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THAT MEANT THAT THOSE
BILLS ARE GOING THROUGH- TWICE
A WEEK ACTUALLY- TRACK IT ON
MONDAY AND TUESDAY EVENINGS SO
WE'D BE TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
BILLS AND THOSE COMMITTEES AND-
HE'S ALWAYS A SOMEONE WHO. WAS
VERY IN. DEPTH GREAT ANALYSIS-
WAS ALWAYS SOMEONE WHO'S A VERY
MEASURED AND- AND SOMEONE WHO
DID A GREAT JOB AND LOOKING AT
THE BILLS AND REALLY LOOK AT
ALL THE DIFFERENT ANGLES HE
ALSO STAFF TWO BILLS. COMPLEX
BILL- AND IT LEAVES US STUCK IN
THE SENATE JUDICIARY RIGHT NOW
SP SIX FORTY TWO ADDRESSING
MISINFORMATION SOCIAL MEDIA SO
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING WHY
HIS SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS
PERHAPS AREN'T GROWING AS FAST
AS THEY USED TO- MAYBE FACEBOOK
GOT SOMETHING TO DO WITH THAT I
DON'T KNOW- AND THEN ALSO HE-
STAFFED SP FIVE NINETY EIGHT-
REGARDING SACRAMENTO RAPID
TRANSIT. HELPING AGAIN HIS
COMMUNITY AND MY CONSTITUENTS
AND ADDRESSING- THAT A PUBLIC
TRANSIT YOU KNOWTHIS YEAR HAS
BEEN A PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING
YEAR FOR THE FELLOWS- AND-
DISCOURSE WITH MOST OF THE
STAFF BEING REMOTE BUT- WE
ALWAYS KNEW WHERE TO FIND A
BOND BECAUSE HE COULD ALWAYS BE
FOUND SO LOSE. AND- SO WE
ALWAYS KNEW WE COULD FIND HIM.
HE ALSO RAISE THE BAR ON ON
DRESS IN THERE FOR THE GUYS IN
THE OFFICE IS ALWAYS THE
SHARPEST DRESSED GUY IN OUR
OFFICE AND WE'RE GOING TO MISS
HIM A LOT- HE'S GOING TO BE
HEADING OUT TO SEATTLE TO
DIVERSITY WASHINGTON TO GET HIS
MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION. I WISH HIM ALL
THE BEST BUT- CERTAINLY HOPING
AND- THAT HE'LL BE COMING BACK
TO CALIFORNIA AND TO
SACRAMENTO- TO BRING HIS
TALENTS BACK TO OUR GREAT STATE
IN MY COMMUNITY AND- HELPING
SHAPE PUBLIC POLICY MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE LESSONS HE
LEARNED JUST HERE'S A FELLOW
AND WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION UP IN DIVERSITY
WASHINGTON SO. CONGRATULATIONS
THE VINE I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR A FANTASTIC JOB AND BEING A
REALLY A GREAT MEMBER OF TEAM
TAN AND- LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING YOUR FUTURE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PLAN LET'S
SAY CONGRATULATIONS TO MISTER
THOMAS AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. AT CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE MADAM READING CLERK
CONGRATULATIONS TO NETANYA
THOMPSON FROM GOLD RIVER
CALIFORNIA IF YOU GRADUATED
FROM BIOLA BIOLA UNIVERSITY
EARNING A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE THE PANEL WAS PLACED IN
SENATOR WILKS OFFICE. SOONER
WOKE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IT'S MIKE STREET MY
EXTREME HONOR TO RECOGNIZE OUR
SENATE FELLOW NATHANIEL
THOMPSON WHAT WE ARE ALL
INTERVIEWING- THIS CROP OF-
FELLOWS WAS NINE MONTHS INTO-
INTO COVE IT. I'M NOT SURE HOW
YOUR OFFICE DOES IT BUT ALL
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE VERY
TALENTED SO IT'S NOT REALLY A
QUESTION OF THEIR TOWNS A
QUESTION OF CHEMISTRY. AND SO
WHEN YOU COME IN INTERVIEW MY
OFFICE YOU NEED ME TO ME YOU
MEET WITH MY TEAM AND HE JUST
ALLOW THEM AND THE REASON WHY I
THINK HE REALLY WELL IS HE-
TOLD THEM. THAT HE LEARNED
DURING COVERT HOW TO CUT HIS
OWN HAIR IF YOU LOOK AT MY
THIRTY IT LOOKS LIKE A
PROFESSIONAL JOB SO NOT QUITE
AS GOOD AS THE- THE GOVERNORS
HERE BUT I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE
THE GENES NOT BECAUSE OF YOUR
SKILL AS A BARBER HOW CAN I
WILL TELL YOU HE'S HE'S THE
REAL DEAL AND IT'S BEEN JUST
REALLY AN AMAZING PERSON. YOU
KNOW DURING COVE INTO YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH AS MENTIONED
EARLIER PRETTY MUCH SHUT DOWN.
AND HE'S REALLY BEEN THE
BACKBONE OF OUR OPERATION HE
WAS IN EVERY DAY MONDAY THROUGH
THURSDAY. SO HE HE ANSWER HE
PHONES. HE DID BILL ANALYSIS
THE STAFF ME HE STEPHANIE ON
COMMITTEES AND THERE'S
LITERALLY NO PROJECT TOO LARGE
OR TOO SMALL THAT HE WOULD NOT
DO. AND DO WELL ALWAYS WITH
CURIOSITY AND PROFESSIONALISM
AND IN A SENSE OF HUMOR. AND
WAS ALWAYS THERE READY TO LEARN
WHEN THE FIRST THINGS HE DID IT
AGAIN HE WAS THERE BY HIMSELF
SO HE DIDN'T HAVE GUIDANCE. IS
I ALSO PUT TOGETHER SOME
TALKING POINTS FOR ME FOR A
REGIONAL PTA- GROUP IS SUPPOSED
TO BE A- TEN MINUTE SPEECH WITH
Q. AND A HE CAME BACK. WITH A
BRIEF ALIKE AND HE WASN'T
NINETY PAGES BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
IT BRIEFING THAT WAS WORTHY OF
A YOU KNOW SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION AND- WHAT THERE'S
WORDS IN THERE COULDN'T
PRONOUNCE I FINALLY HAD TO TELL
HIM. THAT DANIEL I'M A SENATOR
YOU NEED TO DUMB IT DOWN- BUT
HE'S REALLY BEEN AN INTEGRAL
PART OF OUR TEAM AT THE VERY
WELL RESPECTED AND VERY WELL
LIKED AND AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER- HANDLED ALL MY POLICY
COMMITTEES. AND HE JOCKEY THE
MAJORITY OF MY LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THIS YEAR. AND EVEN
WITH COVERED EVERYTHING ELSE I
THINK HE'S HAD AN EXCELLENT
YEAR AND IN YOU ARE DEFINITELY
A CREDIT TO YOUR FAMILY AS WELL
AS THE SENATE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM IN THE SENATE. AND BEST
OF LUCK TO YOU IN YOUR FUTURE
ENDEAVORS AND IF DANIEL
THOMPSON THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME AND CONGRATULATIONS TO
MR THOMPSON AND THANK YOU TOO
FOR YOUR SERVICES STATE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE ABOUT A
MEETING CLLR CONGRATULATIONS TO
VAUGHN THOMPSON FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ONE GRADUATED FROM
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
EARNING A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE BONUS PLACED IN SENATOR
TODD DOES OFFICE SINNER TODDLE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I AM
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THIS YEAR SENATE DISTRICT
FOURTEEN SENATE BELLOMONT
THOMPSON ONE WAS THE FIRST FELL
IN OUR OFFICE AND A GREAT
ADDITION TO OUR TEAM. HIS STAFF
THREE DIFFERENT BILLS SB THREE
EIGHT FIVE AS BEFORE FOR ONE
AND SP SEVEN ZERO FOUR THREE.
HE ALSO BECAME A MASTER AT
LEARNING ABOUT THE BUDGET AND
GETTING SOME MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THEY'RE DONE AS
WELL. HIS HARD WORK COMPASS
BROKER A DEAL THAT FREED UP A
FORMER CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
SITE. IN THE SMALL COMMUNITY OF
SHAFTER SAVING THE COMMUNITY
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR SHOP TO ME NOW
USE THAT FACILITY TO SUIT THEIR
NEEDS RATHER THAN LET IT SIT
VACANT AND PERHAPS EVEN FROM
GOING BANKRUPT BOB BROUGHT HIS
PASSION FOR IMPROVING THE LIVES
OF VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AS WELL AS
HIS PASSION FOR THE SACRAMENTO
KINGS TO OUR OFFICE EVERY DAY
HE ALSO STOPPED ME ON BOTH THE
HEALTH AND AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEES COMMITTEES THAT AS
YOU KNOW. YOU'RE VERY BUSY AND
CAN REQUIRE HIGHLY TECHNICAL
ANALYSIS. HIS WILLINGNESS TO
TAKE ON CHALLENGING WORK HAS
POSITIVE ATTITUDE WILL SERVE
HIM WELL IN HIS CAREER. I AM
VERY HAPPY TO HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH BOND
AND I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHERE
HIS CAREER TAKES HIM BECAUSE I
KNOW HE WILL ACHIEVE GREAT
THINGS SENATORS REPORTING WILL
ALWAYS HOLD A SPECIAL PLACE IN
OUR HEARTS FOR VAUGHN AND
CONGRATULATIONS IN GENERAL IT'S
GIVE ON A ROUND OF APPLAUSE AND
SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU SINNER
TITLES CENTER BRADFORD IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT BETTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
CONGRATULATIONS TO CAPRI WALKER
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA CAPRI
GRADUATED FROM SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY EARNING A BA IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE CAPRI WAS LOW
PLACED IN THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON
CENTRE BRANTFORD THANK YOU AND
IT'S TRULY AN HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE A FELLOW AZTECS SO
THANK YOU MISS WALKER FOR YOUR
SERVICES AGAIN A PRIVILEGE. TO
WORK FOR A ONLY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE BUT ME AS
WELL- IN ADDITION TO THAT SHE'S
ALSO HOUSES DISTINCTION OF
STAFFING ONE OF MY BILLS AND
WORKING. WITH MY PERSONAL STAFF
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING ALWAYS READY AND WILLING
AND VERY INFORMED AND VERY
ENGAGED. IN A ROLE AS A PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERN- CONSULTANT SHE
HELPED ANALYZE NINETEEN SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY BILLS I MEAN FROM.
THE CERTIFICATION USE OF DEADLY
FORCE ON AND ON AND ON VERY
COMPLEX ISSUES THAT WE STILL
ARE GRAPPLING WITH TODAY. AND
ISSUES THAT WE'VE DEALT WITH
OVER THE YEARS- AND PUBLIC
SAFETY NOT ONLY WAS SHE A QUICK
LEARNER. BUT SHE ALSO PROVE
WILLING TO TALK ABOUT ANY TOPIC
AND WAS ALWAYS WILLING TO HELP
WITH ANYTHING THAT CAME UP AND
THAT'S VERY COMMENDABLE BY ALL
THIS FELLS- CINEPHILES I MUST
SAY THEY'VE ALL YOUR GREAT TEAM
PLAYERS. SHE ALSO WORKED ON A
BILL THAT'S NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART- BRUCE'S BEACH ON THE
SITUATION IN MANHATTAN BEACH
THAT THE JUST- HELPING THE
DESCENDANTS OF WILLOW. AND
CHARLES- BRUCE THIS V. SEVEN
NINE SIX- TO RETURN- THIS LAND
TO THIS FAMILY AND THIS IS
LANDMARK LEGISLATION. EVERYONE
WHO HAS WORKED WITH CAPRI HAS
BEEN IMPRESSED WITH HER
PROFESSIONALISM. AND HER
EARNESTNESS. SHE IS ALSO
PROVING HERSELF TO BE A CABLE
WIRE HANDLING LEGISLATURE FLOOD
WORK AND HAS GAINED THE RESPECT
AND TRUST. OF NOT ONLY ME THE
COMMITTEE BUT OVER HER
COLLEAGUES AS WELL.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
MISS WALKER FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AND I WISH YOU
NOTHING BUT THE BEST IN YOUR
FUTURE THANK YOU LASERJET
ELICITED THAT SAY THANK YOU TO
CAPRI. MEMBERS WERE GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR UMBERG
BETTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
REPEAT CONGRATULATIONS TO DAVID
AGUILAR THE THIRD FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA DAVID
GRADUATED FROM UC SAN DIEGO
EARNING A BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE SCIENCE AND SOCIOLOGY
DAVID WAS PLACED AND SENATOR ON
BURKS OFFICE GOOD AFTERNOON
CENTER NUMBER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IF YOU CAN
SEE DAVID UP THERE YOU SHOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT DAVID AND THE
REASON I SAY YOU SHOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT DAVID IS BECAUSE TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW WHEN HE IS
UNITED STATES SECRETARY OF
STATE. YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO
SAY HEY I REMEMBER WHEN HE
WORKED IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE THE REASON I SAY THAT IS
ALREADY HAD A DISTINGUISHED
CAREER EVEN BEFORE COMING TO
US. HE WORKED IN- COLUMBIA WITH
THE U. S. STATE DEPARTMENT
BOGOTA MANY LEAVES HERE IS
LEAVING HERE AS THE THOMAS
PICKERING FELLOW AT COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY NOT THE ONE IN SOUTH
AMERICA THE ONE IN NEW YORK-
WHERE HE'S GOING TO. ACHIEVE A
MASTERS IN INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS. DAVID WAS STAFFING US
ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ITEMS
PRIMARILY TRANSPORTATION WITHIN
LIKE THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPORTATION GOT ONE WEEK TO
TALK TO DAVID ABOUT THAT. PART
DAVID ALSO HANDLE CONSTITUENT
SERVICES IN THE DISTRICT AND
HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS
WHERE HE WAS A COMPLETE TEAM
MEMBER WE ARE VERY SORRY TO SEE
HIM GO BUT VERY PROUD OF DAVID
AND VERY CONFIDENT IN HIS
FUTURE. THANK YOU DAVE
CONGRATULATIONS DAVID THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SENATOR WILL CURE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AFTER LISTENING TO
THE REMARKS OF THE PRO TEN AND
ALL THE MUSINGS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THEIR INDIVIDUAL
FELLOWS I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY
HOW MUCH HAS GONE ON THIS YEAR
AND HOW WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
CODE AND EVERYTHING THAT WE
FACE IN A VERY TOUGH YEAR THAT
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE HAVE TAKEN
THAT CHALLENGE HEAD ON. WE ALL
KNOW THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS
COMPLICATED ENOUGH IN TO
ATTEMPT TO MASTER THE PROCESS
IN A YEAR LIKE THIS SO YOU'RE
LIKE ANY OTHER- JUST
DEMONSTRATES THESE FELLOWS
FLEXIBILITY AND INTELLECTUAL
CAPACITY AND JUST TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU YOU ARE A
CREDIT TO THIS INSTITUTION. I
AM CONFIDENT I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHEN I SAY
THAT THE WORK YOU DO DOES NOT
GO UNNOTICED OR UNAPPRECIATED I
WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
HOSTING FELLOWS FOR THE FELLOWS
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO THE
PUBLIC SERVICE- SERVICE ALSO
MENTION IT WANNA MENTION JAMIE
TAYLOR JUST THE OUTSTANDING JOB
HE DOES SO WITH THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM. SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
EXTEND MY HEARTY
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE CLASS OF
202-020-2020 ONE THAT CLASS
SENATE FELLOWS ON COMPANY YOU
ALL HAVE A BRIGHT FUTURE AND WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN ALL
FUTURE ENDEAVORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME LET'S
GIVE ALL EIGHTEEN FALLS AROUND
OF APPLAUSE AND AGAIN THANK
THEM FOR THEIR WORK AND THE
GREAT WORD FOR MR TAYLOR AND
OVERSEEING SUCH A IMPORTANT
PROJECT THANK YOU NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO CONSIDERATION.
OF THE DAILY FILE I'M SORRY
MESSAGE I'M SORRY I'M SORRY YES
WE'RE MY MOM FOR MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE TEAM READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS. ADOPTED.
MOTIONS TO APPROVE SENATE
JOURNALS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
AUGUST SIXTEENTH THROUGH
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. A FOUR MINUTE
MOTION. THERE'S A FLOOR
AMENDMENTS THAT THE DUST THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. ARE NOW
MEMBERS REMOVED THE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES AND WE
PROVED IT DAILY- SENATE JOURNAL
THING WE DID TO FOUR MINUTES
OKAY AND NOW SENATOR HOW LONG
WERE. SOONER TITLE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS LIKE TO REQUEST A
B. THREE NINETY SIX BE REMOVED
FROM THE FILE FROM CONSENT- FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. BILLY
NOTED. CENTER A CHORE BOKE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AT THE REQUEST OF THE ARTERY
AFTER THE EIGHTY THREE ZERO
NINETY PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR AMENDMENTS PLEASE
SO NO IT SENATOR DOT. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY ONE A. B. TWELVE FORTY
TWO TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THIS
WILL NOTE SENATOR ROTH THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM TWO TO SIX A. B. FIVE
TO SEVEN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS THIS WILL NOTE ANY
FURTHER MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS
CENTER ALAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND AT THE REQUEST OF
THE OTHER WHICH THE COMMITTEE
ON INTER ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS AND
ASSEMBLY SIDE THEY'RE ASKING
THAT WE PULL THE BILL OFF OF
CONSENT AND TAKE IT UP
IMMEDIATELY THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY SIX EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY TWO. SO NO IT SENATOR
BECKER THANK YOU TO PRESIDENT
THROUGH BECAUSE THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM ONE
MOMENT SENATOR BAKER MY POLISH.
SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE THE BILL UP NOW. YOUR
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT ON
THIS MEASURE YES THAT'S RIGHT
YES MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
WHILE I WAS BY. ONE NINETY SIX
FIVE ONE EIGHT SIX. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY TWO BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AN ACT RELATING TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND A CURRENT
URGENCY THERE OF SICK AFFECTS
ME DAILY SIR ALAN FLOOR'S YOURS
MEMBERS THIS IS AS FAR AS
OPPOSITION SUPPORT SPORT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER FOR THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE BILL BUT-
HAS TO DO WITH THE TREE WOULD
WASTE BUT IT'S A PRODUCT OF A
COMPROMISE. THE COMMITTEE BILL
AND I RESPECT FOR US RIVALS
THANK YOU FOR THE DESCRIPTION
OF THE BAY CENTER DAUGHTER- ARE
YOU LOOKING O. OKAY. I'M SECTOR
MATTER CLARK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS HI BASED FIVE BECKER. FIVE
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI BY
ADAM I COURTESY I DALLY I DON
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN I BELIEVE
HER HYPHENS AULUS GROVE FIVE
HURTS BERG FIVE WITH SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES FIVE CAM WALKER
HI FLARED HI LISA THE MON FIVE
WIRE FIVE MELINDA'S FIVE MEN
FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN ARE YOU A
SHOW A BOOK I PAN FIVE FOURTEEN
TINA I. ROSS I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER STERN HI I'M BERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER I
WOKE HI. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO ON THE URGENCY
AUGUST THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOST MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK
TO MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR BECKER A SINNER
CENTERED FOR. YOU GET TO THE
CARD CENTER BECKER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THERE BECAUSE THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE THREE NINE SERVAN TASTES
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
SEVEN MINUTES. THANK YOU TO
JUST WANNA SEARCH FOR. THANK
YOU PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRACE AND THE
AUTHOR. OF FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. B. B. TEN THIRTY
SEVEN A. B. TEN THIRTY SEVEN.
REQUEST TO BE MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. DOES WHO KNOWS
IS THERE ANY OTHER ITEMS UNDER
MOTIONS WROTE RESOLUTIONS. SHE
NINE NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. WE HAVE SECOND READING
FILE MAN CLARK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL. SIX SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU NOW MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS SENATOR
LAYERED ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE IS
CENTERED ALERT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THIS IS THIS ITEM IS THE FIRST
OF FIVE ALL TO THE SAME
COMMISSION- IT'S THE FINAL ITEM
TO SEE CONFIRMATION OF SAMANTHA
ARTHUR FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION. MS
ARTHUR STILL WORKING LANDS
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
JUNE TWENTY THIRD I
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN IPHONE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT
SENATOR NELSON. RIGHT DOWN THE
CENTER I WOULD URGE AND I VOTE
ON ALL OF THESE APPOINTEES TO
THE WATER COMMISSION THIS IS A
VERY CRITICAL BOARD
PARTICULARLY NOW AND I'VE HAD
THE PLEASURE OF DISCUSSING
WATER ISSUES WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THEM. I FOUND THEM
TO BE VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE VERY.
INTERESTED IN THE WATER FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA FORWARD LOOKING
BUT I RESOLVED THEY'RE A GOOD
TEAM I THINK THE MOVE AHEAD AND
AGAIN THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL
COMMISSION RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY AS IT WOULD RELATE
TO WATER STORAGE FOR THE FUTURE
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN I WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE ON ALL OF THESE APPOINTEES
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER-DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINT MENT. HEARING C. NINE
SIR WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE JUST I
THANK SENATOR NELSON FOR HIS
COMMENTS THIS IS THE
COMMISSION. THAT GETS THE MONEY
OUT THE DOOR FOR WATER STORAGE
I ASKED FOR YOUR I. PHONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
APPOINTMENT. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA. HI AT KINS. FIVE
EIGHT. BACKER FIVE PORCHES
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
COURTESY HI DALLY DOT HI THERE
ALSO I AIKMAN FIVE GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES GROVE IT HURTS
BERG HI WITH SO HI HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LIVE ON THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN I A TELEPHONE PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER STERN HI I'M BERG I
WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL.
MMHM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THAT
SOME MEMBERS FAITH FOR JUST
DALLY GONZALES GROSS HER TADO
JONES LAVER MELINDA'S A SHOW OF
BOTH SKINNER WELL. R. S. TWENTY
EIGHT AT NO ZERO THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED CENTER ALERT THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF KIMBERLY
GALLAGHER FOR APPOINTMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
MS GALLAGHER IS THE PRESIDENT
OF GALLIC REFORMING COMPANY AND
ALSO THE MANAGER OF BERGMAN
FAMILY FARMS SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD. I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS APPOINTMENT HERE IN C.
NINE MINUTES AGO- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS I BASE HI BECKER HI
FOR JUST BRADFORD FIVE KOBE
ADAM FIVE CORTEZ HE HI DALLY I
THOUGHT I TORONTO HI EGGMAN
FIVE BLAZER EYE CONSOLIDATES
GROVE FIVE HERZ BERG HI WEST SO
BY HER TADO FIVE JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA THE
MON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S FIVE
MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN FIVE A
TELEPHONE PAM I PERSON TINA
FIVE ROTH IRA RUBIO I SKINNER
STERN I AM BERG I WAKE OUT SKI
I WINNER I WILL HI. PLEASE CALL
OUT SOME MEMBERSHIP GORGEOUS
GONZALEZ LLEVA BUT SHOW BOTH
SKINNER. HIGHS THIRTY FIVE WHO
KNOWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
APPROVED THE EARLIER THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THIS IS FINAL ITEM
FOR THE CONFIRMATION OF ALEX
MACK COLOR FOR APPOINTMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
MR MACKELLAR SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT FOR CALPINE
CORPORATION'S WESTERN REGION HE
HAS BEEN WITH CALPINE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT
HEARING AND SEEING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
FIVE EIGHT FIVE BECKER I
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY I DOT I
DRAW SO I EKMAN I LASER HI
CONSOLIDATES GROSS I HURTS BERG
I WAS SO HYPER TADO FIVE JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I FLAVOR
THE MON HI WIRE I BELINDA'S I.
MIN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN I WOULD
SHOW UP BOTH CAN FIVE FOURTEEN
TINO HI RALPH ALL RIGHT RUBIO
HI SKINNER STERN I AM BERG HI
WHITE HOUSE KING FIVE WINNER I
WILL HI. I'M SECTOR POLICE
CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS FOR JUST
GONZALES LLEVA NEWMAN I A
TROUBLE SKINNER ALL EYES THIRTY
FIVE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON THE FOLLOWING FIVE
CENTERED ALERT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THE ITEM FIVE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE SOLORIO
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION HE
IS CURRENTLY THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS OFFICER FOR THE MULTI
GAL WATER DISTRICT AND RECENTLY
SERVED ON THE SANTA ANA CITY
COUNCIL FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY. HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT
SENATOR BATES I. AM I ON THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF OUR FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE SOLORIO HE
IS WORKING WITH THE WATER
DISTRICT AND ALL REGION AND HAS
RECEIVED UP HI- RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE BALL
AND THE GO WATER DISTRICT BOARD
AND REGARDING HIS ADVOCACY FOR
THE ISSUES OF GREAT IMPORTANCE
TO OUR SOUTHERN ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY. ART URGENT I GO
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT ERNESTINA MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
I FACE HI BECKER I FOR JUST
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM ARE YOU
PROTESTING I DALLY I DON I-
ALSO HI ADNAN I LASER HI
CONSOLIDATES GROSS I HEARD
SPURRED HI WITH SO HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOR THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON
I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN HI I'M BERGERON I
LIKE CASKEY I WINNER I WILL.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
OB TO MEMBERS PORGES GONZALEZ
JONES LLEVA MELINDA'S CONTROL
OF BOTH SKINNER WILKE. ARE YOU
STURDY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM SIX
CENTER ALERT THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
IS A CONFIRMATION OF FERN
STEINER FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
MISSED ON- SOME ATTORNEY AND
SHAREHOLDER AT SMITH STEINER
VANDERPOOL APC WITH OVER FORTY
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT LAW SHE IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
JUNE TWENTY THIRD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM HERE IN C.
NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WITH FALLON I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I HATE
FIVE BECKER I PORCHES BRADFORD
HI I HAVE A. HI CORTESE FIVE
DALLY DOT HI THERE ALSO FIVE
ADMIN FIVE LASER HI
CONSOLIDATES GROVE HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR
LET ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN HI I. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A CHILL OF BOTH HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN HI I'M
BERG HI KELSEY FIVE WINNER I
WILL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS PORGES
BALLY I GONZALEZ GROSS I LABOUR
SKINNER WELL HI ALL EYES THIRTY
SIX NOS ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. X. PART MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE HAVE ONE ITEM-
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. TWENTY
TWO. SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR ADMIN AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS B.
THIRTY THREE IS COMING BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
HAVING TO DO WITH LOCAL
CONTRACTING AND TRANSPORTATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HERE'S A NON NON SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IT'S ALL
DOABLE FOR YOU NOT NEAR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL HERE IN G.
NINE. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO SENATE THIRD READING WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS FIRST UP IS FALL
ITEM THIRTY ONE. M. CLARK
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR WEST SO RELATIVE TO
PUBLIC POWER WEEK. SENATOR
WELLS WHAT SO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK U. S. PRESIDENT
SCR FORTY NINE DESIGNATES THE-
FIRST WEEK OF OCTOBER AS PUBLIC
POWER WEEK AND I URGE AND I
VOTE ON SJR. FORTY NINE. OKAY
ANY FOR THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
VERY THIS TOO IS A DOUBLE FOR
UNIONS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION USING THAT UNITS FROM
ROLL CALL CURRENCY NINE OZ
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FALL
ITEM THIRTY TWO. BY THIS
SENATOR JOE BOOK. MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE ROUTE SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR- TELEVOTE RELATIVE TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURE THE
TROUBLE THE FLOOR'S YOURS MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FOUR RECOGNIZES THE MONTH
OF OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND EACH FOLLOWING OCTOBER AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AWARENESS
MONTH. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AFFECTS ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF AGE SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS
GENDER RACE RELIGION OR
NATIONALITY AND THE DRAMATIC
CONSEQUENCES CAN LAST A
LIFETIME ALTHOUGH PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE TOWARDS PREVENTING
AND ENDING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES
IMPORTANT WORK REMAINS TO BE
DONE IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATED CALLS
AND 7% OF ALL HOMICIDES WERE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATED. THE
MYSTIC VIOLENCE SHELTER PROGRAM
SERVES CLOSE TO NINETEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
SHELTERS AND SERVED ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED AND NINE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS THROUGH NON SHELTER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE PROVIDE
CONTINUED SUPPORT TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH PROVIDE ESSENTIAL LIFE
SAVING SERVICES TO SURVIVORS
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
COMMUNITIES IT IS ALSO
IMPERATIVE THAT WE SHED LIGHT
ON THE GREAT NEED FOR EDUCATION
AND RAISING AWARENESS OF THE
PREVALENCE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. BY UNDERSTANDING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE INDIVIDUALIZED
NEEDS OF SURVIVORS THE MONTH OF
OCTOBER WILL BE A TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DRUG KNOWLEDGE AND
AMPLIFY THE VOICES OF
SURVIVORS. WE ALL HAVE A VITAL
ROLE IN PREVENTING AND ONE DAY
ENDING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR MAN THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- I'M PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHORED THIS BILL AND
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE-
AND MY COLLEAGUES FOR AUTHORING
THIS MEASURE. MISSING VALANCE
IS ONE THE MOST VEXING ISSUES
OF OUR TIMES IS FAR MORE
PREVALENT THAN MOST PEOPLE
REALIZE ENDEMIC STATISTICS SHOW
THAT ONE IN THREE WOMEN AND ONE
I NINE MEN EXPERIENCE SOME
FORM OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. BUT SINCE THE START
OF THE PANDEMIC. THESE NUMBERS
HAVE SKYROCKETED WHILE MANY OF
US WERE SHELTERING AT HOME TO
STAY SAFE FROM THE PANDEMIC.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. HOME IS
ANYWHERE BUT SAFE. WE HAVE SO
MUCH TO DO AND I THINK THERE'S
SUCH SO MANY COMMON
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE- THOSE WHO LEARNED
ABOUT THIS ISSUE I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT THIS
FROM MY WIFE WHO IS A LEADING
EXPERT IN THIS AREA- I.
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ISOLATED INCIDENTS OF VIOLENCE
IT'S ABOUT A CYCLE OF CONTROL
AND ABUSE THAT BEGETS ITSELF.
ON CREATES A VICIOUS CYCLE- I'M
PROUD TO HAVE AUTHORED A NUMBER
OF KEY- MESSICK VIOLENCE.
MEASURES THIS YEAR INCLUDING
ONE AT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO
LAW SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR- I
THINK WE HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO
DO IN THIS SPACE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO TAKE THE
LEAD HERE WE NEED TO PROTECT.
FAMILIES CHILDREN FROM THE
VEXING EFFECTS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND SENATE
COLLEAGUES TODAY I ALSO WRITE
AND STRONG SUPPORT AND AS A
PROBLEM JOIN AUTHOR ON S. C. R.
FIFTY FOUR WHICH PROCLAIMS
OCTOBER IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AWARENESS MONTH I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM YUCAIPA
FOR BRINGING SUCH AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND ALSO ON MY
COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE FOR BEING
A STRONG ADVOCATE ALONGSIDE ME-
WE DID A CO AUTHOR BILLS THIS
YEAR AND SOMETHING FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP I WILL REPEAT THE
STATISTICS TO SHARE BY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY BUT THE
NUMBERS ARE REALLY. ALARMING
AND I DON'T WANT TO LOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALWAYS KEEP
REMINDING THOSE THAT HAVE
CHILDREN THAT A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS NOT JUST PHYSICAL
AND THAT'S WHAT WE TEND TO LOOK
FOR PHYSICAL SIGNS OF ABUSE
LET'S ALWAYS KEEP VERY VIGILANT
AND LOOK FOR SIGNS OF CHANGES
IN BEHAVIOR ESPECIALLY IF YOU
HAVE TEENS IT IS A DRAMATIC
CHANGE IN THE PERSONALITY THE
WAY THEY DO THINGS ALWAYS ASK
THE QUESTION NOT JUST ARE YOU
BEING ASSAULTED BUT ARE YOU
BEING COERCED AND THAT IS ALSO
AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO REPEAT.
I AM ALSO LET'S NOT BE AFRAID
TO REPORT UNUSUAL BEHAVIOR OR
IF YOU SEE SEVENTEEN BECAUSE
THAT MAY MEAN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH FOR THAT
PERSON THAT MAY BE ASSAULTED
AND PLEASE CALL AND GET THEM
HELP OUT WITH THAT I. URGE AND
IDLE THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE IN CINA CENTER
TROUBLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I VOTE
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE I'M THIRTY TWO.
I'M SORRY THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL MY GOD ANY
OBJECTIONS TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS MEASURE
HERNICI NINE AUGUST THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY FOUR. BY
SENATOR EDMUND. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR EDMUND
RELATIVE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTER AGREEMENT I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND- AND
MEMBERS BUT TODAY I RISE TO ASK
THAT WE DECLARE AUGUST AS H. P.
B. MONT AWARENESS MONTH HPV IS
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF
CERVICAL AND THROAT CANCER. IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THE THE
NUMBER ONE I. STI THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW COVERT HAS THROWN OFF
EARLY DETECTIONS OF SOMETHING
THAT WESHOULD ALWAYS BE
SCREENING FORGAN DETECTED FOR
CATCHING IT EARLY CAN PREVENT
ALL KINDS OF CANCERS. WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BRING IT TO OUR
AWARENESS SO WITH THAT MEMBERS
I WOULD ASK- THAT WE DECLARE
THE SENATE JOINS ME IN
DECLARING. AUGUST AS HPV
AWARENESS MONTH AND DECREASE
OUR RATES OF STI IN CANCER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE SENATOR PAT THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT TO SENATORS I TO
RISE AND STRONG SUPPORT AT THIS
R. FORTY SIX ONE THING MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM STOCKTON FOR BRING
THIS FORD. HGVS PREVENTABLE SO
ALL THE CANCERS THAT- WE SEE
AND THE PEOPLE WHO DIED OF
CERVICAL CANCER PENILE CANCER
AND ALL CANCER ALL THESE
CANCERS THAT ARE CAUSED BY
THESE FIRES ARE PREVENTABLE AND
WHY WOULD WE NOT PREVENT THEM
AND SO THIS AWARENESS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND DIET
URGENT I VOTE ON SR FORTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE HERE IN CHINO AND
SENATOR EDMUND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTED THANK THE SENATOR
FROM SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY SIR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS.
FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER HI FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD FIVE CABRERA
I PROTESTING I DALLY FIVE DOT
HI THERE ALSO HI FIVE EGGMAN
FIVE LASER HI CONSOLIDATES
GROVE HERTZBERG HI WITH SO FIVE
FURTADO I JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA THE MON HI WIRE
I MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN HI A TRIO OF BOTH HI
PAM FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I. ROSS
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER STERN HI
I'M BERG I WACO SKI I WINNER I
WILL HI I'M SORRY SIR PLEASE
CALLED ABBAS A MEMBER GONZALEZ
GROVE I LABOUR SKINNER ALL EYES
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
ITEMS HERE ARE FIRST UP THIS
FALL ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. I'M. BY
SENATOR BY ASSEMBLYMAN
MISSOURIAN SENATE BY SENATOR
WINNER ARE YOU PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AN ACT
RELATING TO STREETS CENTER
WINNER THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE BY 2% EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE ON BEHALF
OF A SUMMER MEMBERS AREA- THIS
LEGISLATION AUTHORIZES LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO MAKE TEMPORARY
SLOW STREETS AND THE PERMANENT
FIXTURES- ADDITIONALLY AB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE AUTHORIZES US
CITIES TO DESIGNATE A LOCAL
STREET ART WITHIN ITS
JURISDICTION AS A SLOW STREET.
ASSOCIATES BEGAN- AFTER THE
PANDEMIC STARTED IN OAKLAND AND
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
OTHER CITIES THE IDEA BEING TO
IDENTIFY STREETS WERE THROUGH
TRAFFIC- WOULD BE- PROHIBITED.
LIMITING SPEEDS SO THAT PEOPLE
COULD USE THE PAVEMENT FOR
EXERCISE AND RECREATION DURING-
THE PANDEMIC A WAY OF USING
STREET SUCH AS FOR CARS- BUT
FOR PEOPLE AS WELL- THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE WAS
IMPLEMENTED TEMPORARY PROGRAMS
DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT HAVE
CREATED MORE THAN FIFTY MILES
OF SLOW STREETS FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST. RECENT
STREETS ARE INCREDIBLY POPULAR
AND PEOPLE HAVE REALLY
APPRECIATED. BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THAT ADDITIONAL SPACE FOR
RECREATION AND FOR INCREASED
SAFETY HI THIS TREND HAS BEEN
SPREADING ACROSS. THE COUNTRY
AND WE NEED TO EMPOWER AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SIMPLY ALLOW
CITIES TO MAKE THE SIDE STREETS
PERMANENT IF THE CITY CHOOSES
TO DO. SO. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU ANY FOR JUST OR
THE ON THE SIDE IN NINETEEN
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WITH FALLON I ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS I BASE BACKER HI
FORGES BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
POTENTIALLY I DALLY NO DOG FIVE
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I GLASER'S I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
FIVE WEST SO FIVE HER TADO FIVE
JONES CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA LIMO ONE. FIVE MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN FIVE NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM I FORTINO I. ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN I NUMBER FIVE
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER I
WILL HI. I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSA MEMBERS FAITH NO
PORCHES GONZALES JONES LLEVA
SKINNER. MARCH THIRTY KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES NO
MEMBERS WERE MVING ON TO FALL
ITEM EIGHTY TWO. SENATOR WINTER
FOR SOME WOMEN'S JOY. THE TRUE
ANSWER. I'M SECTOR PLEASE RE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATIONAL AND
EQUITY CENTER WINNER I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I'M NOT
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE TWO
FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
ON A SUMMER NUMBER TWO.
COLLEAGUES TRANSGENDER AND NON
BINARY STUDENTS FACE MANY
BARRIERS AT SCHOOL AND IN THE
WORKPLACE- IF A STUDENT DOES
NOT HAVE AN UPDATED DIPLOMA OR
TRANSCRIPT- THEY CAN FACE
CHALLENGES APPLYING FOR GRAD
SCHOOL OR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- BECAUSE OF THAT
DIPLOMA OR TRANSCRIPT MAY NOT
MATCH WITH THEIR ACTUAL GENDER
IDENTITY AND THE ACTUAL NAME- A
COLLEGE DIPLOMA IS A
REPRESENTATION OF YEARS OF HARD
WORK AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
IT SHOULD NOT CAUSE STRESS OR
EMOTIONAL HARM BY HAVING
SOMEONE'S BIRTH NAME OR DEAD
NAME AS THE CALLER ON IT DUE TO
OUTDATED DOTTED SCHOOL POLICIES
EIGHTY TWO FORTY FIVE THOSE TWO
THINGS FIRST IT ALLOWS
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
STUDENTS AT PUBLIC COLLEGES TO
HAVE THEIR CHOSEN NAME PRINTED
ON THEIR DIPLOMA WHEN THEY
GRADUATE SECOND TO CREATE THE
STANDARD PROCESS FOR UPDATING
ITS STUDENTS RECORDS- AS FORMER
STUDENTS. SO THAT LATER ON IN
LIFE- THEY CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR CORRECT GENDER AND NAME
ARE ACCURATELY REFLECTED ON
IMPORTANT COLLEGE RECORDS BY
TRANS AND NON BINARY PEOPLE
FACE SO MANY EXISTING BARRIERS
THE NAME ON A DIPLOMA SHOULD
NOT BE ANOTHER ITEM FOR THEM TO
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT- THE STILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND SPONSORED
BY OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND
BUY QUALITY. CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. ANY
FURTHER IS VERY ON THE SAW HERE
IN CHINO MENTORED SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FOLLOWING ME
TO. ALAN HI FIVE ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I BASE NO BACKER HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI COURTESY FIVE DALLY NO
GOD HI THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ GROVE NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI FURTADO
HI JONES NO CAMCORDER I LAYERED
FIVE LABOR THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH I PAM
I FOURTEEN TO NO I. ROSS HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER STERN HI
AMBERG HI KELSEY HI WINNER I
WILL KNOW. ARE YOU SWOONING
DONNA KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE OVING
ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
BISON ROMMEL'S. SAID SENATOR
LEHRER HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBR RAMIS AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE CAPITOL
SOONER OR LATER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OUR CALIFORNIA IS
KNOWN FOR MANY THINGS ONE OF
THEM BEING A RICH HISTORY AND
DIVERSITY WELL THE HISTORY O
OUR STATE CONTAINS PIECES OF
INJUSTICES AND WRONGS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE STORY IS
ALSO ABOUT MOVEMENTS THAT
FOUGHT FOR DEMANDED JUSTICE
EQUITY AND CALLS. TO RIGHT
THOSE WRONGS MANY OF US ON THIS
FLOOR PARTICIPATED IN THOSE
MOVEMENTS AND SOME OF US IT'S
WHAT INSPIRED US TO GET
INVOLVED IN PUBLIC SERVICE THE
GOAL OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THREE EIGHT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROM MOST IS TO
UP LIFT ANOTHER DIVERSE VOICE
AND EXPERIENCE. THE STATE
CAPITOL ON CAPITOL GROUNDS
SHOULD CONTAIN CELEBRATED
MONUMENTS THAT ARE REFLECTIVE
OF THE BEST OF OUR STATE'S RICH
HISTORY AND DIVERSITY. JUST
LAST SUMMER THE STATUE OF
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS AND QUEEN
ISABELLA WAS REMOVED FROM THE
ROTUNDA BECAUSE IT FELL SHORT
OF THAT GOAL WELL THE STATUE
MAY HAVE BEEN APPROPRIATE BACK
IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE IT WAS
NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA WE CELEBRATE TODAY.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEMBERS TODAY I HAVE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AND I
HAVE TO- PROVIDE. UP LEAVE HIS
PLANTATION WHY BECAUSE-
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL- MAKE
SOME REPRESENTATIONS THAT ARE
NOT ONLY. FALSE IT INCLUDES
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT IS
NOT HISTORICALLY ACCURATE AND
IT'S- I THINK IT POSES SOME. OF
SOME X. OF REQUIREMENTS. OF
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
ARE COMPLETELY UNACHIEVABLE BY
ANYONE THAT WE HONOR IN OUR
HISTORY I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY-
WELL YOU KNOW WE TOOK AN ACTION
AGAINST CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
AND I OFTEN ASK PEOPLE WHAT WAS
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS'S
ACHIEVEMENT AND THEY SAY DOES
HE DISCOVERED AMERICA AND OF
COURSE THERE'S BEEN A DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER HE DID THAT
BECAUSE AMERICA ALREADY
EXISTED. AND THAT'S NOT WHAT HE
IS RECOGNIZED FOR IN SCIENCE
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS DID NOT
DISCOVER AMERICA WHAT HE DID
WAS YOU RE UNITE HUMANITY. THAT
WAS SEPARATED BY A GEOGRAPHY
GEOGRAPHICAL CHANGE A CHANGE
THAT SEPARATED PEOPLE THAT ONCE
WERE ABLE TO CROSS OVER THE
BERING STRAIT WHEN THE BRIDGE
CREEK WAS ELIMINATED YOU HAD. A
COMPLETELY NEW NEW CULTURES
WERE FORMED THAT EXISTED IN
AMERICA FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
AND NATIVE AMERICANS BECAME A
VERY DIVERSE GROUP OF PEOPLE
RANGING ALL OF THE AMERICAS
SAID OF DEVELOPED IMPORTANT
SCIENTIFIC. DISCOVERIES INFORM
NEW CULTURES BUT NEVER ONCE
PART. OF THE HUMANITY THAT
EXISTED IN IN AFRICA ASIA
EUROPE AND THEN THEY WERE
SEPARATED. THE SAILING ACROSS
THE ATLANTIC BY CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS IS CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE MOST. IMPORTANT HUMAN
ACHIEVEMENTS IN ALL OF HUMAN
HISTORY SIMPLY BECAUSE HE
REUNITED HUMANITY SO WE WERE
TAUGHT THAT IF YOU PUT IN A IF
YOU SAY ON THE TEST THAT HE
DISCOVERED AMERICA YOU GOT A N.
A. AND ALL OF US WERE
INDOCTRINATED TO SAY HE
DISCOVERED AMERICA FALSELY WE
GET IT WRONG BECAUSE
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS MADE A
CONTRIBUTION TO THE AMERICAS
THE NO OTHER PERSON IN HISTORY
HAS MADE AND OF COURSE HE HAD
HIS SINCE. HE HAD HIS SENTENCE
AND OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE
RECOGNIZE PEOPLE WE KNOW THAT
THEY HAD SINCE IN THE CASE OF
COOPER OF SEVEN. COOPER SAID
ABOUT IS BEING ACCUSED OF
THINGS THAT HE DIDN'T ACTUALLY
DO COOL WAS TWENTY PER CENT
RACKLEY PERSONA DREAMED. OF
THROUGH HIS ISHANT IN THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH OF EIGHTEEN AND
PEOPLE TO HIS RELIGION TO
CREATING COMMUNITIES AND HE
CAME HERE SPECIFICALLY FROM
SPAIN THE MEXICO CITY AND HE HE
WENT ON A VERY DIFFICULT
JOURNEY. TO COME HERE TO CREATE
COMMUNITIES THESE COMMUNITIES
DID NOT INVOLVE SLAVERY PLEASE
COMMUNITIES DID NOT INVOLVE
TORTURE NOT NONE OF WHAT HE
ENVISIONED WOULD HAVE REQUIRED
THAT HE HAD THIS VISION OF
COMING HERE AND CREATE CREATING
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD
WORSHIP HIS GOD THAT IS SO MUCH
IN TUNE WITH OUR OWN VALUES AS
A PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY AND IF
YOU LOOK AT. OF OUR HISTORY
THAT'S VERY MUCH OF WHAT A LOT
OF US BELIEVE A LOT OF US TRY
TO GET PEOPLE TO JOIN OUR TEAM
OUR PARTY. OUR OUR GROUP IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT HUMAN
BEINGS DOING DO OVER OR THERE
IS NO COUNTRY THERE'S NO
SOCIETY THERE'S NO GROUP THAT
USED WAR OR CONFLICT AS A MEANS
OF NOT ONLY PROTECTING
THEMSELVES FOR ADVANCING THEIR
GOALS NOTHING IN IN IN AMERICA.
IT'S FREE FROM THAT OUR HISTORY
IS ABOUT WAR. IT'S ABOUT
CONFLICT IN SOME OF OUR BIGGEST
HEROES OUR OUR OUR OUR FIGURES
ARE HISTORICAL FIGURES THAT
WERE SOLDIERS THAT WERE PEOPLE
THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL THAT'S NOT
REALLY A FEW MORE OIL IS DOWN
TO ITS MAKING WAR CONFLICT AND
pSUCCESSFUL COUNTRIES AND THAT
IS AND WE STILL POSSESS THE
LARGEST MILITARY IN WORLD
HISTORY THOSE ARE STILL. OUR
VALUES AS A COUNTRY WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH THEM OR NOT. IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT MAKES US
THE WORLD POWER THAT WE ARE IN
SO OUR HISTORY. IS SOMETHING
THAT EVERYONE HAS PARTICIPATED
IN THAT IS CONTRIBUTED IN
MAKING WHO WE ARE SO WHY IN
PARTICULAR SCRUTINY SPECIAL SET
OF IT BEING PUNISHED. HE'S
ACTUALLY THE ONLY PERSON IN
AMERICAN HISTORY. WHO
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED FOR
NATIVE AMERICANS AND PUT LAWS
IN PLACE TO PROTECT NATIVE
AMERICANS SO WHY IS HE BEEN
ACCUSED ACTUALLY OF. HER NAME
VIOLATING INSULATING NATIVE
AMERICANS THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION BECAUSE HE DID NONE OF
THAT. ONE OF THE LAWS THAT HE
PUT INTO PLACE REQUIRED THE
REMOVAL OF THE ACTING GOVERNOR
AT THE TIME WHO WAS WHO WAS
HARMING NATIVE AMERICANS SAID
HE DISAGREED WITH THAT AND THE
ONLY WAY HE THOUGHT HE COULD
PROTECTED OF AMERICANS WAS TO
REMOVE THAT FIGURE WHICH IS
SUCCESSFULLY DID THE NEXT THING
THAT HE ADVOCATED FOR WAS THAT
THE NATIVE AMERICANS. ACTUALLY
BE ALLOWED TO INTEGRATE INTO
COMMUNITIES AND EVENTUALLY ON
LAND THAT'S NOT EVEN SOMETHING
THAT WE ALLOW TO DIE BUT HE DID
MET NUMEROUS THINGS TO ADVOCATE
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HE'S ACCUSED OF IN
A COMMENT HE MENTIONED SHACKLES
OF PUTTING PEOPLE IN SHACKLES
BECAUSE BACK THEN THEY DIDN'T
HAVE JAILS OR PRISONS AND HE
WAS MAKING A COMMENT TOWER UP
HOLDING THE LAW AND ANYBODY
THAT BROKE IT. INCLUDING NATIVE
AMERICANS SHOULD BE SHACKLED
BUT THAT WAS VERY MUCH IN TUNE
WITH OUR VALUES TODAY WE
BELIEVE IN LAW AND ORDER WE
BELIEVE IN MAKING LAWS AND IF
ANYBODY DOESN'T RESPECT THEM
THEY SHOULD BE PUNISHED AND HE
WAS CREATING A SOCIETY OF
ORDERS WILL AS HE SOUGHT SO HE
WAS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PEOPLE IN OUR HISTORY AT
CREATING COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE PERSISTED
THAT NOW CREATED SOME OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT CITIES IN THE
WORLD AND TO OUR STATE. THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO ADDITIONAL CITIES
LIKE MON MODERATE IMPORTANT
CITIES C. R. THESE ARE
IMPORTANT COMMUNITIES BUT HAVE
A FOUNDATION IN SOMETHING THAT
HE STARTED. BUT DID NOT BUILD A
LONG NONE OF THIS HE DID A LOT
AND NONE OF THIS WAS ENTIRELY
AS HE ENVISIONED BUT NATIVE
AMERICANS WERE VERY IMPORTANT
TO ANYTHING HE DID THEY WOULD
NOT BEEN A SINGLE COMMUNITY
BUILT IF IT WASN'T. FOR THE
INVOLVEMENT AND PARTICIPATION
OF NATIVE AMERICANS AND THAT IS
OFTEN MIS CHARACTERIZED SAYING
THAT HE HELD A GUN TO THEIR
HEAD AND SAID YOU MUST DO
SOMETHING THAT IT'S- NOT
ACCURATE EVERY TIME NATIVE
AMERICANS IN A MISSION
COMMUNITY WERE MISTREATED. THEY
REBELLED AND THEY BURNT DOWN
THE MISSIONS THEY THEY ENDED
MANY MISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
FROM ARE FROM CALIFORNIA ALL
THE WAY TO BACK ON THE PHONE A
LOT WERE NATE DIDN'T END IT
BECAUSE THE NATIVE AMERICANS
REFUSED TO PARTICIPATE. AND
THEY ACTUALLY MADE WAR AGAINST
THE SETTLERS AND THEY KILL THEM
AND A LOT OF THOSE MISSIONS
FAILED IN IN IN SAN DIEGO A
MISSION THAT- SO FAR- NOW ST
CRITICAL SET UP FUND IT IN
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE THAT WAS
ENOUGH OPERATING IN IN
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. THAT
LED TO THE KILLING OF SOME
PRIESTS WERE THERE. AND THE
BURNING OF THE MISSION AND CAN
BETTER COOPER SAID I HAD TO
TRAVEL FROM MONTEREY BACK TO
SAN DIEGO BUT THEN IMAGINE
TRAVELING DOWN THERE WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT THING. AND WHEN HE
WENT BACK THE MISSION WAS RE
ESTABLISHED NOT BY FORCE NOT BY
MILITARY POWER. BECAUSE NATIVE
AMERICANS RESPECTED HIM AND
THERE WAS A THERE WAS A
MISUNDERSTANDING. LED TO THAT
THAT WAS CORRECTED AND SO THESE
COMMUNITIES WOULD HAVE NOT
ASSISTED IF IT HAD BEEN FOR THE
USE OF SLAVERY IN MILITARY
MIGHT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE STRENGTH AND
THE POWER THAT NATIVE AMERICANS
HAD THEY WERE VERY LARGE
COMMUNITIES MADE UP OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
THEMSELVES AMAZING WARRIORS
NATIVE AMERICANS WERE
INCREDIBLE WARRIORS OFTEN
FOUGHT AMONG THEMSELVES AND
OFTEN EVEN ENSLAVED OTHER
TRIBES SLAVERY WAS A THING OF
THE DAY AND I NEED TO SPEAK TO
SLAVERY BECAUSE SLAVERY IN THIS
BILL IS GROSSLY GROSSLY
MISREPRESENTED BECAUSE WHAT IT
MAKES REFERENCE TO A LAW THAT
WAS PASSED BY THE KING IN THE
SIXTEEN HUNDREDS THAT OUTLAWED
SLAVERY AND THE OUTLAWED THE
SLAVERY OF NATIVE AMERICANS IT
FILLS OUT LOUD BUT HOW COULD
THEY ENGAGE IN AND WHO NEED
MENTAL SET ALSO. DID NOT
SUPPORT SLAVERY IN FACT.
SLAVERY WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WAS REALLY. IN IN PUT IT INTO
LAW IN MEXICO WAS ACTUALLY
OUTLAWED. IN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINE BECAUSE SLAVERY BEGAN TO
BE INTRODUCED INTO MEXICAN
TERRITORY THROUGH TEXAS. ONE
EIGHT OUTLAWED SLAVERY THAT
CREATED THE CONFLICT THAT MADE-
TEXAS SEPARATE FROM MEXICO BACK
IN THE THIRTIES AND IT BLED IT
WAS ALL A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
ELIMINATION OF SLAVERY IN
MEXICO SO IN IN ADDITION TO
THAT SLAVERY WAS NOT ALLOWED IN
IN IN- CALIFORNIA THINGS WILL
IT REALLY WENT WRONG IN
CALIFORNIA IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
WHEN CALIFORNIA BECAME A STATE
IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY THE FIRST LAW
THE PAST WAS A LAW THAT ALLOWED
THE SLAVE AND SLAVE MINUTES OF
NATIVE AMERICANS THROUGH A LAW
THAT ALLOWED- CALIFORNIANS TO
KILL NATIVE AMERICANS AND TO
TAKE THEIR CHILDREN. AND TO
INDENTURE ANY NON NATIVE
AMERICAN BASIS ALL IS NOT
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED AND THAT WAS
A FORM OF SLAVERY THAT WAS
ALLOWED BACK THEN BIG GAVE
RISE. TO THE EXTERMINATION OF
NATIVE AMERICANS THE REAL
PROBLEMS BEGAN IN CALIFORNIA
AGAINST THE NATIVE AMERICANS IF
THEY WERE HAVING PROBLEMS THE
REAL ONE STARTED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY. AND THERE WERE PEOPLE
THAT WE HONOR TODAY IN OUR
STATE GROUNDS AND IN OTHER
PLACES THAT TOOK A HAND IN
INSULATING THE INDIANS IN
MISTREATING THEM AND KILLING AN
ACTUAL GENOCIDE LOVE IN FACT WE
HAVE A THE ENTIRE WHOLE
RECOGNIZING GOVERNORS THAT
PASSED LAWS IN THIS VERY
BUILDING AGAINST NATIVE
AMERICANS I DON'T SEE US
REMOVING THEIR NAMES I DON'T
SEE US REMOVING THEM FROM THE
GROUNDS I DON'T SEE US BOB-
TEARING DOWN THIS BUILDING
WHICH IS AS MUCH A SYMBOL OF
COLONIZATION IS ANYTHING ELSE
INCLUDING WHAT WE DO AS A
GOVERNMENT I AM VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSED TO EVERYTHING THAT IS
HAPPENING THIS PROCESS BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW GROWING UP AS A LATINO
IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S HARD TO
FIND HISTORICAL FIGURES THAT
MADE A CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
SOCIETY THAT COME FROM MY
HERITAGE FOR MY BACKGROUND.
THAT PART OF NATIVE AMERICAN
DESCENT. OF SPANISH DESCENT OR
MEXICAN DESCENT MOSTLY OUR
HISTORY IS VILIFIED THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND GROWING UP IN
THE STATE WITHOUT HEROES FOR A
PUBLIC FIGURES TO LEARN FROM AN
ASPIRE TO AND LEARN THAT IN THE
STATE THAT I WAS BORN IN THEY
WERE. LATINOS AND- ITS PARTNERS
MAKING HISTORY HERE. LONG
BEFORE I WAS BORN DATING BACK.
215-402-2160 WE HAD PEOPLE
MAKING HISTORY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT NONE OF
THEM ARE REFLECTED WHEN WE
FINALLY GOT ONE THIS MONUMENT
THAT WILL BE REMOVED TO PUT IT
BUT ARE SET ON THE GROUNDS AND
HOW DO I KNOW. IT WILL BE
REMOVED BECAUSE I GOT
CONFIRMATION FROM THE AUTHOR
THE IT WILL BE REMOVED. AND
THIS BASICALLY BILL SETS UP THE
PROCESS TO REMOVE. A MONUMENT
THAT IS NOT A HISTORICAL ALL OF
THE HISTORICAL VALUE AND
PROTECTED UNDER CALIFORNIA LAWS
THIS BILL DOES NOT AT ALL MAKE
MENTION OF THE FACT THAT THAT
IS A HISTORICAL SITE. AND IT
SHOULD BE PROTECTED BUT IT PUTS
IT ON THE PATH TO BE REMOVED
THEY'RE REMOVING STARKEL FIGURE
THAT IS OF SPANISH HERITAGE THE
ONLY ONE THAT WE HAVE. AND
REPLACING IT WITH A MONUMENT TO
NATIVE AMERICANS WHICH I
BELIEVE IS A HAVING A MONUMENT
TO A NATIVE AMERICANS I THINK
IS ESSENTIAL BUT BUILDING IT ON
A HISTORICAL SITE OF HONOR
SOMEBODY THAT MADE A HUGE
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR STATE IS A
HUGE MISTAKE CREATING A SCAR
YOU'RE CREATING AN EMOTIONAL
SCAR AND ON THAT YOU'RE GONNA
PUT ANOTHER MONUMENT THAT.
HONORS A DIFFERENT GROUP OF
PEOPLE I AM BOTH NATIVE
AMERICAN AND SPANISH DESCENT
AND I'M VERY PROUD OF BOTH MY
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE AND MY
SPANISH MEXICAN HERITAGE AND
THIS BILL MAKES ME CHOOSE
BETWEEN ONE OR THE OTHER AND
ALL OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE OF SPANISH DESCENT AND
NATIVE AMERICAN SAID IT DOES
THE VERY SAME THING THE AUTHOR
HIMSELF IS OF SPANISH DESCENT
AN UPDATE OF AMERICANS SAID HIS
NAME ROMMEL SAYS A SPANISH NAME
HIS TRIBE SOMEONE WHEN SOMEONE
WILL IS AS THE NAME OF HIS ST
SPANISH NAME AND HE IS OF THE
SERVER I KNOW PEOPLE A NAME
GIVEN TO THEM BY THE SPANISH
CALIFORNIA IT IS A PLACE OF
DIVERSE CITY ALL OF US HERE
SHOULD CELEBRATE EACH OTHER AND
ALTHOUGH THE FIGURES GEORGE
WASHINGTON FOUGHT AGAINST THE
NATIVE AMERICANS HE KILLED
NATIVE AMERICANS AND HE OWNED
SLAVES BUT THE CONTROVERSIAL
TEENAGER ACTUALLY TO SPEAK TO
THE MEASURE I AM OKAY AND THAT
IS RELEVANT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT ACTING TO REMOVE
ANYONE THAT IS OF ENGLISH
DESCENT BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
ITALIAN WHEN IT COMES TO
SPANISH THAT IS LOW HANGING
FRUIT IN THIS COMMUNITY AND
THIS IS WHERE I CAN NOT
PARTICIPATE IN DIMINISHING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF PEOPLE FROM MY
COMMUNITY SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT ADHERE. TO ONE GROUPS.
THE REQUIREMENTS OF WHAT IT IS
TO BE A NOTABLE PERSONALITY IN
HISTORY YET COMPLETELY IGNORES
COMPLETELY IGNORES EVERYONE
ELSE BUT WE HONOR THAT HAVE
SINCE SO I KNOW THIS IS GONNA
BE REMOVED BECAUSE I TRIED TO
WORK THIS OUT WITH THE AUTHOR
AND INITIALLY THERE WAS AN
INTENT. THAT WE WERE GOING TO
SIT DOWN AND TALK THIS OVER.
BUT I KNEW THAT WHEN I FIRST
GOT A LETTER SAYING I WILL
SCHEDULE A MEETING FOLLOWED BY
A LETTER SAYING I'VE DECIDED
THE MEETING WILL BE ON THIS
DATE IN THIS TIME PLEASE CALL
MY OFFICE TO CONFIRM WHEN I
TRIED TO CALL HIS OFFICE. TO
SET THE DATE AND TIME AND TO
INCLUDE. OTHER LEADERS OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
COMPLETELY REFUSED HE HAD THERE
WOULD BE NO RIGHT YOU CONCLUDE
YOUR REMARKS IF POSSIBLE I WILL.
AND AT THE VERY END HE HE SENT
ME A LETTER SAYING THAT I'M
WRITING TO INFORM YOU THAT MY
OFFICE WILL BE REACHING WITH
THAT I I'M SORRY. I HE
BASICALLY SAID I HAVE HONORED
OUR ARTICLE GREENMAN TO
PARTICIPATE IN A MEETING WITH
YOU AND THE SPONSORING TRIBAL
LEADERS THIS FULFILLS MY
PROMISE I HAVE A THE SPONSORS
TRIBE HAVE AGREED TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE EIGHTY THREE THREE
THREE EIGHT IN ITS CURRENT FORM
A MEETING THAT NEVER TOOK PLACE
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
LETTERS BE SENT TO HAVE A
MEETING BUT THAT WAS. THE WAY
THIS WENT DOWN. WITHOUT NO
ABILITY TO PROVIDE INPUT I THIS
IS WHY I FEEL VERY SAD THIS IS
SAD DAY FOR ME HAVING TO
WITNESS. I KIND OF FEEL THIS IS
AN ATTACK ON MY COMMUNITY
POLICE ON HALF OF MY COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THE OTHER HALF WANTS TO
SEE A MONUMENT. AND THE OTHER
HALF WANTS TO CONTINUE TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED FOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS WE'VE MADE IN
HISTORY AND FOR THAT I DON'T
THINK THIS BILL IS IT DESERVES
YOUR SUPPORT. I THINK WE SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO WORK THIS OUT AND
CREATE A MNUMENT TO BOTH OR AT
LEAST ALLOW US TO WORK
SOMETHING OUT. THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WITH HISTORY
AND ALSO. PAYS TRIBUTE TO THE
CONTRIBUTIONS PEOPLE OF MADE
FOR HISTORY THAT DESERVES TO BE
RECOGNIZED. I ASKED YOU TO JOIN
ME IN VOTING NO AGAIN IT'S A B.
THREE THREE EIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR HUESO SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE IT WITH THE
FULL BODY SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED IN
SENATE GOP. COMMITTEE
REGARDING- AB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT MANY OF US. ARE LAID OFF
ON THE VOTE ON THAT ON THAT
PARTICULAR DAY OR MAYBE I
SHOULD SPEAK FOR MYSELF I LAID
OFF. ON THE VOTE THAT DAY
WANTING TO SUPPORT A B. THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. AND I THINK IN
THAT- THERE'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ELEMENT THAT WE COULD CONSIDER
HERE AND SEVERAL OF US ASK THE
AUTHOR TO CONSIDER. AMENDING
THE BILL. TO MAINTAIN IN THE
HOOD OF HER SERRA- MONUMENT
HERE IN THE CAPITAL BUT ADD TO
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS OF PROPER-
HONOR. AT TO THE NATIVE
AMERICANS THAT LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND- HAVE. OCCUPIED
CALIFORNIA BEFORE EUROPEANS GOT
HERE AND YOU KNOW JUST
PERSONALLY I THINK THAT THAT'S
A SIMPLE REQUESTED- SOME OF US
HAVE MADE THAT I WISH THE
AUTHOR WOULD HAVE HONORED. I
THINK WE CAN DO BOTH I THINK WE
CAN. HONOR BOTH THE HERITAGE OF
AN APPARENT SERRA. AND THE
HERITAGE OF OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN- RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA THEY WERE HERE
BEFORE ANY OF US WERE. AND SO I
WAS HOPING THAT'S WHERE WE
WOULD GET TO WE DIDN'T AND SO-
I JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE BODY
THANK YOU THINK CENTRE JOAN
SENATOR ALSO YES SIR HEY DIDN'T
INTEND TO GET UP TO SPEED BUT I
THINK THAT- SENATOR WESSEL
RAISES SOME VERY IMPORTANT AND
LEGITIMATE ISSUES HERE AND
CONCERNS UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS THE EXACT
EXACT THIS IS THE EXACT CASE IN
WHICH I COULD REALLY FIGHT FOR
AW- THE INCLUSION OF ALL WHEN
YOU GET A NEW BETTER SANTA TOO
MANY TOO MANY CONFLICTING AND
SOME VERY VERY STRONG ARGUMENTS
AS TO WHY E SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE TO BE HERE AT THE
CAPITOL MANY NOT JUST ONE OR
TWO. AW I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHAT SENATOR WESSEL
SAID SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO IS
THAT THERE IS A PART OF HISTORY
THAT'S GOING TO BE TOLD THROUGH
THE STATUTE OF A OF A NATIVE
AMERICAN AND INDIGENOUS PEOPLES
ARE DEDICATED TO THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES OF THE STATE AND I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT BUT
THERE IS AS THE SENATOR SAID
ANOTHER PART A SIGNIFICANT PART
WHICH IS THE ROLE OF MEXICANS
IN THIS STATE AND THAT. IS NOT
BEING TAKEN APPEAR AND WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THAT WE JUST UNDER
THE CENSUS KNOW THAT. LATINOS
ARE THE LARGEST GROUP HERE IN
THE STATE SO THERE'S MANY MANY
THINGS THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
ADDRESS UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS ALL THOSE
CONCERNS AND ALL THOSE ISUES-
BUT WE DO NEED TO DO THAT
INSTEAD OF PITTING. ONE GROUP
AGAINST ANOTHER SO WHY WHY WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL I AGREE IN SO
MANY WAYS WITH THE SENATOR FROM
SAN DIEGO SAID AND WE HAVE TO
FIX IT AND WE WILL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO FIX THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN MEMBERS- VERY
INTERESTING DISCUSSION I DO
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR- HIS
EXPOSITION AND ALL THE
INTERESTING THINGS HE HAD TO
SAY I AGREE THAT THERE ARE SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE IN THE AND
INTENT LANGUAGE HERE THAT I
THINK GOES A LITTLE FAR I THINK
THAT- PART OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
IS THAT FATHER SET EYES.
BASICALLY AND A SYMBOL OF THE
ENTIRE OUR MISSION SYSTEM AND
ALL OF ITS EXCESSES- BECAUSE
THAT'S PART OF WHY HE WAS
COMMEMORATED IN THE FIRST
PLACE- LIKE SO MANY I MEAN THE
AND WE TALKED ABOUT CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS IN MANY RESPECTS HE
IS. CELEBRATED WERE VILIFIED
BECAUSE HE'S A SYMBOL IS A
SYMBOL OF. OF NOT ONLY THE
DISCOVERY BUT THE ULTIMATE
COLONIZATION ALL THE PAIN AND
HARDSHIP THAT WAS INCURRED- I
GUESS I HEARD WHAT I I'M
CERTAINLY DISTURBED HERE THE-
THE LACK OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE AUTHOR AND OUR
COLLEAGUE THAT'S REALLY DOES
CONCERN ME I THAT WAS THE
EXPECTATION COMING OUT OF JAIL
COMMITTEE- I WILL SAY THAT I
I'M NOT SURE THAT I AGREE WITH
THE SENATORS CHARACTERIZATION
OF THIS PARTICULAR CITED
HISTORICAL SITE. OF THE STATUE
WENT UPIN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN- YOU KNOW TO BE HONEST I
I'VE I WENT SAW THAT STATUE
MANY TIMES DON'T BELIEVE THAT
TO HAVE PARTICULAR AESTHETIC
MERIT HI. THERE'S NO THERE'S
NOTHING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
SITE- WITH HISTORIC HISTORY
WITH HISTORIC- A STORY OF
FATHER SAT OUT THE MISSION
SYSTEM I JUST HAPPEN TO BE A
SITE THAT WAS CHOSEN ON OUR
CAPITOL GROUNDS. ARE THERE
STILL MANY ALLUSIONS TO THE
MISSION SYSTEM HERE IN THIS
BUILDING OUR FATHER SERRA'S
NAME- IS MENTIONED ON SOME
MURALS- IT NOBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT TAKING DOWN HIS STATUE AT
CARMEL WHICH OF COURSE IS A
SITE THAT'S VERY MUCH CONNECTED
WITH HIS LEGACY IN A STORY- SO
YOU KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
THIS IS THAT. THIS IS NOT A
IT'S SPECIAL PLAY THEY WERE
ABOUT WITH REGARD TO. A SARIN
HIS LEGACY AND LET'S ALSO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THE
STATUE IS NO LONGER STANDING
THE QUESTION HERE IS- IS NOT
WHETHER IT'S NOT ABOUT TAKING
DOWN A STATUE- IT'S ABOUT
WHETHER TO PUT IT BACK UP AGAIN
OR INSTEAD. TO PUT A MONUMENT-
REFLECTING THE INCREDIBLE
HERITAGE OF OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY I'VE NOW IT'S TRUE
THE MINUTE WAS TORN DOWN TORN
DOWN BY- THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
VANDALISING. OUR CAPITOL
GROUNDS AND SO THAT'S A THAT'S
A DIFFICULT QUESTION AS WELL
BUT I GUESS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THIS SITE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR SIGNIFICANCE. TO OUR
TO THE HISTORY- THAT A YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE DO NEED
TO HAVE A GREAT NEED OF
AMERICAN- MONUMENT HERE ON THE
SITE I FELT COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. IN
COMMITTEE- I CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THOUGH I
WILL SAY I'M NOT ENTIRELY
COMFORTABLE WITH ALL THE
LANGUAGE IN THE INTENT. OF THE
BILL AND ALSO I'M CERTAINLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
AUTHOR AND ARE CALLING AND I
HOPE. THAT IF THIS BILL MOVES
OUT OF AFTER THE SENATE FLOOR
AND SOME OF THESE. CONCERNS CAN
BE RESOLVED WE CAN GET SOME
CLARITY FROM THE OTHERS OFFICE
SOME MORE DIALOGUE BETWEEN OUR
COLLEAGUES SO AS TO GET AT
LEAST SOME OF THESE ISSUES-
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED TO DRESS
I HADN'T. SO THOSE ARE MY
THOUGHTS. ON ON THIS BILL THEY
RE AND ANNA AND I AND I DO WANT
TO COMMEND. OUR COLLEAGUES FOR-
FOR HIS PASSIONATE AND WHARTON
DISCUSSION- AND THE POINTS THAT
HE RAISED WITH REGARDS TO WHO
IS CELEBRATED WHO ISN'T THERE
SOME FASCINATING DISCUSSIONS
HAPPENING RIGHT DOWN IN NEW
MEXICO OVER SOME SOME OF
SIMILAR TYPES OF ISSUES WITH
REGARD TO SPANISH COLONIZATION
TENSION BETWEEN. LATINO
COMMUNITY AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES LOOKS
BACK- AND AS AND AS MUCH AS OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID SO OFTEN THOSE
TWO COMMUNITIES ARE SO
INEXORABLY INTERTWINED THAT IT
LEADS TO SOME VERY DIFFICULT
AND FASCINATING ISSUES WITH THE
RELATION TO IDENTITY AND
HISTORY THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
HI FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE VERY ELOQUENT OF TRIP
DOWN NOT HISTORY LANE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO IT
WAS QUITE AMAZING TEETH TO BE
REMINDED OF THE MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LEARNED ABOUT
WERE NOT ACCURATE AS WE TRAVEL
THROUGH THE EDUCATION OUT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE VERY TRUE.
WHAT'S TROUBLING TO ME- IN THE
CURRENT FORM THE MEASURE MISSES
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO HELP
UNITE PEOPLE OF CONSTRUCTING-
YEAH WELL TO TRIBAL NATIONS IN
SACRAMENTO TO CONSTRUCT AND
MAINTAIN A MONUMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PEOPLE OF THE
REGION ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
STATE CAPITOL THAT IS A
WONDERFUL THING THAT'S A VERY
GOOD THING. AT THE SAME TIME IT
DOES NOT ALLOW US TO RESTORE-
D. V. ST UNIT PEARL SERRA
MONUMENT ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
CAPITOL WHICH WERE ILLEGALLY
REMOVED- THROUGH WRITING SO WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY I BELIEVE
FIVE IF WE HOLD ON THIS BILL WE
HAVE ENOUGH TIME LEFT IN THE
SESSION TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
MODIFICATION THAT DOES ALLOW
THE RESTORATION OF THE
UNIVERSAL SERRA A MONUMENT AND
AT THE SAME TIME SET ASIDE A
LARGE PORTION OF OUR CAPITAL
GROUNDS. TO RECOGNIZE THE
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
NATIVE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
I THINK IT IS OUR OUR DUTY HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE THEY HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS PAST PRESENT AND
FUTURE- WE ARE ONE PEOPLE AND
TO BEGIN TO DIVIDE OURSELVES
OVER YOU KNOW THE FLAWS OF OUR
ANCESTORS AND OUR FOUNDERS OF
SUNDAY WILL ALL BE JUDGED ON
THAT ALSO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY I THINK FOR ALL OF
US. TO BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
RIGHT FOR BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE JUST ALLOW A LITTLE MORE
TIME AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR BRINGING OUT FORAGING.
HAVING US ALL DO A DEEPER DIVE
INTO OUR OR- ARE OUR THOUGHTS
BUT TE PASS FOR AND THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
FOR WITHOUT I'D ASK THAT WE
JUST PUT IT OVER. TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT IT AND BRING IT BACK IN
A DIFFERENT FORM THANK YOU.
THANKS INTERVIEWED SENATOR
BORDERS.
IS THIS WORK NOW HERE
WE GO WELL. MR PRESIDENT MAY-
MAY PLEASE- POSE A QUESTION TO
THE FOUR SPONSOR OF THE BILL
EARLIER WOULD YOU TO QUESTION
SURE SHOOT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT CALIFORNIA I CAN BARELY
HEAR YOU MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
PRESERVATIONIST COMMISSION OR
MONUMENTS COMMISSION I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT STILL IN
EXISTENCE- BUT- WOULD THIS NOT
BE AN APPROPRIATE. ISSUE TO
PRESENT TO THAT COMMISSION MADE
UP OF FOLKS WHO ARE WELL
SCHOOLED AND DISCIPLINED IN- IN
HISTORY AND MONUMENTS FOR US TO
GIVE A BETTER SENSE ON. WE'VE
HEARD COMMENTS ABOUT THE
AESTHETIC VALUE OR QUESTION THE
ASCETIC VALUE IN HISTORICAL
VALUE WAS THIS IS THE ISSUE
EVER BROUGHT TO THE COMMISSION
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE BUT I CAN
TELL YOU HAS BEEN A PRIOR
SECRETARYSHIP THAT COMMISSION
WAS IN A DEPARTMENT THAT WAS IN
MY AGENCY AND IT IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF ITS
AUTHORITY WITH WHAT REGARD DO
YOU DESCRIBE. BECAUSE IT IS
REALLY ABOUT HISTORIC
PRESERVATION OF BUILDINGS OR
OTHER ITEMS AND IT MIGHT TALK
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF THOSE
BUILDINGS BUT- THIS WOULD NOT.
FALL WITHIN IT ADDITIONALLY THE
CAPITAL IS ALWAYS UNIQUE AND
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE CONSIDERING THIS I
WAS GOING TO MENTION IN MY
CLOTHES SO ONE OF THE FIVE THIS
IS DIFFERENT MAN PORTRAITS OF
GOVERNORS OR EVEN A FAN OF THE
CARMEL MISSION. BECAUSE THIS
WAS ENACTED BY LAW AND ALL THIS
DOES IS FOR THE FIRST HALF OF
THIS ALL IT DOES IS JUST REPEAL
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE A
STATUTE THERE'S NO REQUIREMENTS
ABOUT THOSE GOVERNORS
PORTRAITS. OF THE CARMEL STATUE
IS ON PRIVATE LAND OUTSIDE OF
THE GOVERNMENT CONTROL SO IT
WOULD BE NOT WITHIN I THINK THE
PURVIEW OF THAT COMMISSION AND
HOW THEY'RE STRUCTURED IS THERE
ANOTHER BODY WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
APPROPRIATE TO REVIEW A MATTER
LIKE THIS IN CURA MEMBER OF
STAFF ONE BODY. BECAUSE BECAUSE
IT WAS THE LEGISLATURE THAT
REQUIRED THE STATUE BY LAW IT
IS THE LEGISLATURE THAT CAN
DEAL WITH IT AND IT'S A
LEGISLATURE THAT THAT SORT OF
HAS CONTROL OVER THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS OKAY BUT THENOUTSIDE
OF. THE LEGISLATURE THERE'S NO
OTHER NOT DIRECT MISSION TO MY
KNOWLEDGE TO MY KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET MY UNDERSTANDS THAT
THERE THAT THERE WAS. A STATE
MONUMENTS COMMISSION AND I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S STILL
STANDING CURRENTLY. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW. S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE FATHER HAD A PAIR
OF SERRA WAS AN EIGHTEENTH
CENTURY SPANISH FRANCISCAN WHO
WAS A CO FOUNDER OF OUR STATE
AND BROUGHT CHRISTIANITY TO
CALIFORNIA- MANY MISSIONS AS
IT'S BEEN STATED- ARE BECAUSE
OF WHAT HE DID TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE MISSIONS WERE AN
ESTABLISHED ESPECIALLY OVER IN
THE COASTAL REGION REGION AND
HE'S REASON THAT SO MANY TOWNS
BEER- THE NAME OF ST INCLUDING
CITY OF ANGELS LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO SAN RAPHAEL IN SAN
DIEGO JUST TO NAME A FEW
ALTHOUGH I AM VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF CONSTRUCTING A
MONUMENT IN CALIFORNIA FOR
NATIVE AMERICANS AND THAT-
WE'RE HERE. IN THE STATE IN THE
NATION AND ALSO CONTRIBUTED
GREATLY TO THIS COMMUNITY IN
OUR STATE. I ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN C. AND T. DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY CAN'T BE
TO. A ONE THAT HONORS- JUNIPERO
SERRA. SERRA AND THEN ALSO OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO'S
COMMENTS AND I APPRECIATE THE
HISTORY LESSON THAT HE GAVE HIM
THAT HE GAVE ALL OF US. YOU
KNOW- BECAUSE OUR HISTORY ISN'T
PERFECT. BUT IT'S OURS. AND
ERASING IT AND SIMPLY ERASING
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT GO AWAY. AT
ALL AND I THINK M. RECOGNIZING
WHAT OUR HISTORY IS IN THE
STATE IN THIS NATION WILL HELP
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE UNDERSTAND-
NOT TO MAKE THE SAME MISTAKES
IN THE PAST. SO EVEN THOUGH I
pKNOW IT'S I KNOW IT'S NOT YOUR
MEASURES DURING YOUR CARRYING
THIS AND FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMEAU'S. IS THERE SOME TYPE OF
AGREEMENTS THAT COULD BE MADE
OR TO MIMIC CAN BE TAKEN TO
HONOR BOTH. OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ON OUR CAP IN THESE
GROUPS. THE INDIVIDUAL JUNIPER
SERRA AND THEN THE GROUPS AND
THE NEED AMERICANS ON OUR
CAPITOL GROUNDS. AND I THINK
YOU SORRY QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR APOLOGIZE SIR SOONER WE
TOOK HER LESSON YES AND
ACTUALLY THE QUESTION WAS
ALREADY OFFERED. A SO LET ME
SAY ONCE AGAIN MAYBE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. THIS BILL JUST
RECALL PEELS THE REQUIREMENT TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THE STATUTE.
LEAVES OPEN A DISCUSSION SUCH
AS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT EVEN
THOUGH IT PROACTIVELY SETS UP A
PROCESS. TO HAVE A STATUTE.
THAT ARE OWNERS INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE SO IT LEAVES THAT OPEN
BUT IT CLEARLY RECALL OF. A
REPEALS THE ABSOLUTE
REQUIREMENT THE WE HAVE THE
STAFF TO WHOM THE PEROT SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM IN NINETEEN
NINE CENTER ALERT WHICH
ARTICLES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
LET ME THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
FOR THEIR COMMENTS BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A REAL
TRIBUTE TO THE DISCUSSION THAT
NEEDS O HAPPEN AND IN FACT
HAPPENED HERE TODAY IN MANY
WAYS. AND ERR ON THE SUBSTANCE
OF THE BILL I JUST REPEAT ORDER
I HAVE SAID TO TWO QUESTIONS
THE BILL REPEALS THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE STATUE AND
SETS UP A PROCESS FOR A STATUE
OF INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND I
THINK THAT THE TOUGH THING. IS
SOME OF THE FACTS ABOUT HISTORY
ARE IN DISPUTE- THE FATHER SIR
WAS CRITICIZED BY SPANISH
GOVERNORS AND OTHER EUROPEAN
OBSERVERS AT THE TIME AND THERE
IS A BOOK BY THE PULITZER
NOMINATED AUTHOR AFFILIATE
DISCUSS DO THAT REALLY
DOCUMENTS THE THINGS THAT THAT
WERE RAISED ABOUT THIS. SUBJECT
AND IT IT ALSO IN THE
DIFFICULTY OF THE DISCUSSION I
MEAN POPE FRANCIS CAME TO SOUTH
AMERICA AND APOLOGIZED TO
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES FOR THE
GRAVE SINS OF COLONIALISM. AND
SO I THINK THAT IT WAS ALSO
OFFERED ON THE FLOOR THAT ARE
MONUMENTS AND OUR CAPITAL NEEDS
TO BE REPRESENTED
REPRESENTATIVE OF MANY
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY. I THINK WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE IS A CLEAR
STATEMENT. THAT THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED AND THAT ALL OF US
HAVE TO TAKE IT UPON HERSELF TO
CONTINUE THAT PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE IT HAPPENS AND THEN I
THINK THAT WAS SET ON THE FLOOR
NOT. A GOOD THING SO- THE ONE
LAST THING I'D SAY IS IT'S
INTERESTING IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SUPPORT AND THE OPPOSITION. THE
SUPPORT IT IS REALLY FIFTEEN
TRIBES WERE REPRESENTATIVES OF
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS AND IT IS
THEIR VOICE THAT'S SPEAKING TO
WHAT THEIR VIEW OF HISTORY YES
AND IT IS IMPORTANT. TO HEAR
THAT FORCE BECAUSE THE STRUGGLE
IN DIFFERENT PEOPLE IT AND
DIVERSITY OF MONUMENTS IS
LISTENING TO THE INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLES OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THEIR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND
THAT IS WHAT IS BEING SPOKEN
TO. IN THIS BILL IT GOT OFF THE
ASSEMBLY FOR SIXTY SIX TO TWO
THE PAST GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION TWELVE TO ZERO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE THANK YOU THE MADAM
SINCE ALL THE DEBATE HAS SEIZED
ON THIS MEASURE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE. ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE
BACKER HI FORTUS BRADFORD
CABRERA CORTEZ THREE FIVE DOLLY
DOT I THEY'RE AWESOME BY ADMIN
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS GROVE
HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO NO HER
TADO JONES NO CAMERA UNDER
LAYERED HI LLEVA THE MON HI
WIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN I
NIELSEN BUT SHOW A VOGUE FIVE
PENN FIVE FORTUNE TINO ROTH
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN HI
I'M BERG I Y. CASKEY I WINNER
FIVE WELL HI. I'M SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS ALAN I
BAYTEX PORGES BRADFORD I
CABRERA I DALLY. I GIVEN I.
GONZALEZ GROVE. HER TADO I CAN
LONGER. I LLEVA MELINDA'S MANY
NIELSEN FOURTEEN TINA I SKINNER.
MARCH TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TOO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
IF IT'S NOT WITH THE OBJECTION
WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE FRONT TO
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS WERE GONNA
MOVE THE FILE I DON'T EIGHTY
EIGHT FOLLOW ADAM ONE FIFTY SIX
AND FOLLOW ALLY I AM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN AND THAT. ORDER SENATOR
MAN ARE YOU PREPARED FOR. FALL
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT. A. B. FIVE
OH SIX HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
OH SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
YOUTH SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS
SOONER MEN. HEY MR PRESIDENT
EIGHTY FIVE OH SIX WOULD
REQUIRE YOUTH SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO IMPLEMENT
SPECIFIED CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MEASURES. IN RECENT
YEARS INCREASED STATURE
LIMITATIONS AND MEDIA ATTENTION
HAVE HEIGHTENED OUR AWARENESS
OF THE PROBLEM OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ABUSE IN SCHOOLS
CHURCHES SPORTS TEAMS AND YOUTH
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS. FOR
INSTANCE OVER NINETY THOUSAND
CLAIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ABUSE HAVE BEEN FILED AGAINST
THE BOY SCOUTS OF AMERICA.
EVIDENCE SHOWING INTERNAL FILES
TRACKING THE IDENTITIES ANDCRIMES OF HUNDREDS OF
PERPETRATORS OR SCOUT LEADERS.
OR OTHER ADULT VOLUNTEERS
HOWEVER SUCCESS SUSPECTED ABUSE
WITHIN THE BOY SCOUTS WAS OFTEN
NOT REPORTED TO POLICE. AND
ORGANIZATION CONTINUALLY FAIL
TO TAKE MORE PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES SIMILARLY OVER TWO
HUNDRED CLAIMS OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ABUSE WERE FILED AGAINST
THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB. WHICH
FAILED TO REPORT ABUSE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IN SOME CASES
FAIL TO RUN BACKGROUND CHECKS.
ON STAFF. DESPITE INTERNAL
POLICIES TO THE CONTRARY WHILE
MANY YOUTH ORGANISER HAVE
ADOPTED GOOD INTERNAL BEST
PRACTICES THEY'RE STILL LACK OF
UNIFORM STANDARDS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY EIGHTY FIVE OH
SIX WOULD CREATE BASIC MINIMUM
STANDARDS. TO PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE AND YOU SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND REQUIRE
TRAINING ON CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT IDENTIFICATION AND
REPORTING FOR MINISTRY- SIMPLE
REASON REGULAR VOLUNTEERS. AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CHILD
ABUSE ABUSE PREVENTION POLICIES
SUCH AS HAVING TO MANDATED
REPORTERS PRESENT WHEN IN
CONTACT WITH CHILDREN TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE S. A FORMER BOY
pFATHER OF YOUNG CHILDREN WHO
ARE IN THE CUB SCOUTS I THINK
THESE ARE REASONABLE
APPROPRIATE MEASURES TO ENSURE
THAT OUR CHILDREN ARE SAFE THAT
THEY RECEIVE THE BEST OF THE
VALUES THAT THESE TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONS OFFER. WITHOUT
HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT THE
DOWNSIDE RISK OF PREDATORS IN.
THIS BILL PASSED SENATE
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY AND
RECEIPT HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HEARING SEEN NONE IT'S
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION FOR
USE IN A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
A. B. FIVE OF SIX. HERE IN C.
NINE ALL EYES THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON
TO FALL ITEM. ONE FIFTY SIX.
BUYS SAID SOONER- SOMEONE
WOMAN- ROENTGENS ALL AS
PRESENTED BY SENATOR ROTH.
SENATOR ROTH ARE YOU PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS
CENTER OFF THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE LAST
FEW YEARS HAVE SEEN A SURGE IN
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS
ENTERING THE FOOD SERVICE IN
EXCHANGE FOR LISTING A
RESTAURANT ON THE PLATFORM AND
PROVIDING DELIVERY SERVICE
RESTAURANTS TYPICALLY PLAY PAY
PLATFORMS A COMMISSION ON THEIR
SALES AND CONSUMERS ALSO PLAY A
VARIETY OF FEES INCLUDING
SERVICE DELIVERY FEES IN
ADDITION TO THE FEES PAID BY
RESTAURANTS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY SIX SIX A NUMBER OF
STEPS TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
TO RESTAURANT OWNERS AND
CUSTOMERS ABOUT THIRD PARTY
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL NOW
REQUIRES FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE ONE
PURCHASE PRICE OF FOOD AND
BEVERAGE TO A GENERAL NOTICE TO
CONSUMERS THAT THE PLATFORM
CHARGES A FEE TO THE FOOD
FACILITY UNLESS THE FOOD
FACILITY ITSELF DIRECTS THE
PLATFORM TO DISCLOSE THE
SPECIFIC FEES. CHARGED BY THE
PLATFORM THREE ANY FAKE
COMMISSIONER COST CHARGED TO
THE CONSUMER BY THE PLATFORM
CAN ANY TIP OR GRATUITY. THE
BILL MAKES IT UNLAWFUL FOR FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS TO CHARGE A
CUSTOMER ANY PURCHASE PRICE FOR
FOOD OR BEVERAGE THAT IS HIGHER
THAN THAT LISTED ON THE WEBSITE
AT THE TIME THE ORDER IS
PLACED. THIS ENSURES PLATFORMS
ARE NOT PASSING ON DESHAUN FEES
IN THE FIRST IN THE PURCHASE
PRICE ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
MAKES IT UNLAWFUL FOR PLATFORMS
TO RETAIN ANY PORTION OF
AMOUNTS DESIGNATED. AS A TIP OR
GRATUITY THEREBY ENSURING THOSE
ARE PAID TO THE APPROPRIATE AN
INTENDED RECIPIENT I II THE
DELIVERY PERSON OR IN THE CASE
OF A PICK UP ORDER. TO THE FOOD
FACILITY THIS TRANSPARENCY WILL
EMPOWER CONSUMERS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH
PLATFORMS TO UTILIZE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HEARING CENA MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THEM THE
ROLE ON FALL I DON'T WANT FIFTY
SIX. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE NO BECKER HI FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE
CORTEZ THE HI DALLY NO DOT I
TORONTO BY ADMIN GLAZER. FIVE
DOLLARS GROVE NO HERTZBERG FIVE
WEST SO HI HER TADO SORRY JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA THE MON I REQUIRE FIVE
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI FIVE NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN NO A TRIO OF BOTH
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN HI
I'M BERG HI WHAT KASKY FIVE
WINNER I WELL NO NO. THE
OBSERVATORY PLEASE CALL THAT
SOME MEMBERS EGGMAN. GONZALES
LLEVA A TRIO OF BOTH SKINNER
THE- PRICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN LORETTA GONZALES
SENATOR WAY SURE YOU'RE
PREPARED FOR THAT MEASURE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO SOLID WASTE
SENATOR WAS FOR THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
CENTER SYSTEM AGE OLD PROBLEM
THAT'S FINALLY BEEN ADDRESSED
A. B. EIGHT EIGHT ONE WOULD
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN CALIFORNIA
LAW THAT CURRENTLY ALLOWS
EXPORTED MIXED PLASTIC WASTE TO
BE COUNTED AS RECYCLED EVEN
WHEN IT IS ACTUALLY LANDFILL
BURNED OR DUMPED. WHEN
CALIFORNIA SORT OF PLASTIC IN
THEIR BLUE BINS THEY SOON BUT
WHAT THEY SORT OUT WILL
ACTUALLY BE RECYCLED INTO NEW
GOODS THIS BILL WOULD RESTORE
CALIFORNIA'S RATE THE RISK FOR
CYCLING TO MAKE SERIOUS
PROGRESS TOWARD ON WASTE
DIVERSION GOALS BY
RECLASSIFYING THE EXPORT OF
MIXED PLASTIC WASTE AS DISPOSAL
ALLOWING TRULY RECYCLABLE
PLASTIC EXPORTS. TO CONTINUE TO
BE COUNTED TOWARDS OUR
RECYCLING GOAL THIS BILL HAVE
YOU RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE HERE IN
C. NINE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION WITH USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FOLLOWED
A ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. HEARING C.
NINE OZ THIRTY SEVEN. NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING BACK TO FALL ITEM
ONE ELEVEN. ONE ELEVEN BUY A
CINNAMON MERECE SU CHI SENATOR
ALTHOUGH SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARTUCCI AN ACT
RELATING TO CARE FACILITES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY BERRA
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY SANTA
ROSA THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT A.
B. TWO SEVENTY NINE WILL
PROVIDE NECESSARY PROTECTIONS
TO SENIORS DURING THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BY
PROHIBITING INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES FROM TERMINATING
TRANSFERRING OR SIGNIFICANTLY
ALTERING THE CONDITIONS OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE SERVICES
DURING THE CALL BUT NINETEEN
STATE OF EMERGENCY PERIOD.
SENIOR LIVING IN THESE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE ESPECIALLY
DURING THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THEM FROM
A RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES THE BIG
CHIN OR TRANSFER TRAUMA FROM
THEIR HOME IT IS UNCONSCIONABLE
TO FORCE RESIDENTS OUT OF A
VIABLE FACILITY AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC THE
CURRENT PROTECTIONS HAVE NOT
SLOWED THE RATE AT WHICH
FACILITIES ARE INVOLUNTARILY
TRANSFERRING AND DISCHARGING
VULNERABLE AND ELDERLY
RESIDENTS ONE EXAMPLE IS IN MY
OWN DISTRICT THE SAKURA GARDENS
AN INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY.
ARE TRADITIONALLY FOR JAPANESE
SENIORS IN BOYLE HEIGHTS THE
OWNERSHIP PACIFICA'S ATTEMPTING
TO BREAK THEM AND RELOCATE THEM
TO ANOTHER ONE OF THEIR
FACILITIES WHICH HAS SOME OF
THE WORST DEATH RATES DURING
THE PANDEMIC THIS MEASURE IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AND THEIR LOVED
ONES THE PEACE OF MIND KNOWING
THAT THEY WILL NOT BE FORCED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES DURING THE
PANDEMIC I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HERE IN SAINT HELENA
BONHAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FALL ITEM ONE
ELEVEN. ALAN I ARCHULETA. I AT
KINS. HI BABES FIVE BACKER FIVE
FOUR JUST BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE FIVE DALLY HI TODD
FIVE TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES GROSS HERTZBERG
I WAS SO HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED FIVE LLEVA
THE MON I MCCOY- HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO
A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE
TINO I. ROSS I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER EARN HIGH NUMBER FIVE
WHAT KIND OF SKI I WINNER I
WILL HI MINS MINUTE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS
PORCHES GONZALEZ GROVE WESTERN
I LLEVA SKINNER. DALLY I TO
KNOW. ALL THREE DOLLARS THIRTY
TWO KNOWS THREE ON THE URGENCY
ALL EYES THIRTY TWO KNOWS THREE
ON THE MEASURE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WE
HAVE A FEW A JOURNEY MEMORIES
WE'RE GONNA START WITH SENATOR
LOTT MON ARE YOU PREPARED.
AFTER THE MON WILL MOVE TO
BATES. AND THEN BRADFORD.
SUGARMAN MALONE I'M SORRY
SENATOR LAMAR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU I RISE TODAY
TESTS THAT WE JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF LEO LEAD JOSEPH
MULLED OVER LEE PASSED AWAY
LAST MONTH AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY ONE HE SERVED THE SANTA
BARBARA COMMUNITY FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS STARTING FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHEN HE
FIRST ARRIVED TO SANTA BARBARA.
HE WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
DEVOTION TO OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH HIS REGULAR ATTENDANCE
AT BOARD OF SUPERVISOR MEETINGS
CITY COUNCIL SESSIONS PUBLIC
RADIO COMMENTARY SANTA BARBARA
MANY ARE OPENING GALA EVENTS
AND CONCERTS IN THE PARK D. WAS
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING OUR
COMMUNITY HE WAS A SUPPORTER OF
THE VICTORY STREET THEATER AND
LAST IN THE LAST INDEPENDENTLY
OWNED MOVIE THEATER IN SANTA
BARBARA HE WAS MOST ACTIVE WITH
THE SANTA BARBARA CHAPTER OF
THE AUDUBON SOCIETY THE
CITIZENS PINE ASSOCIATION THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND. THE
GABBY OTA COAST CONSERVANCY AND
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
FOUNDATION. HIS PASSION FOR
SOME OF OUR POLITICS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC LAND USE
VOLLEYBALL AND CINEMA WILL NOT
BE FORGOTTEN. A SOURCE OF
INFORMATION ON THE LATEST
HAPPENINGS AROUND SANTA BARBARA
LEE OFTEN STOP BY MAY SIMPLY
OFFICE TO SHARE. UPDATES AND
INVITE ME TO EVENTS THROUGHOUT
THE AREA HE TAKES EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. INFORMATION THAT
HE COULD THEN SHARE WITH OTHERS
INCLUDING A WORKSHOP I HOSTED
ON THE GOVERNANCE OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. LEE MOVED CALMLY
AND GRACIOUSLY THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITY AND WILL BE MISSED I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN LEE'S
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HEART'S DEEPEST CONDOLENCES OR
WHAT I SHOULD BRING THE NAME
FOR IT SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO SENATOR BATES TO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. GET THIS THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- I RISE TODAY
TO ENGINE IN THE MEMORY OF
STAND CUMMINGS THE FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN INSTITUTE
A FORMER CONSTITUENT AND A
FRIEND OF MINE STAND TRAGICALLY
PASSED AWAY ON JULY THIRTEENTH
DUTY INJURIES FROM A CYCLING
ACCIDENT IN WASHINGTON STATE
DAN EARNED HIS PHD IN SCIENCE
AND TEACHER EDUCATION FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. HE WAS WIDELY
KNOWN AS A VISIONARY FOR HIS
EFFORTS AND FOUNDING THE OCEAN
INSTITUTE IN DANA POINT. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH
WAS ORIGINALLY CALLED THE
ORANGE COUNTY MARINE INSTITUTE
BUT YOU CAN SEE THE OCEAN
INSTITUTE IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WITH THE GROUND BREAKING
ON THE SIXTEEN AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLAR OCEAN EDUCATION
CENTER. IN TWO THOUSAND WHICH
IS PROBABLY ONE OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS TODAY THE
INSTITUTE SERVES APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED THOUSAND VISITORS
EACH YEAR. IT CONTINUES TO
FULFILL STANDS LEGACY THROUGH
PROGRAMMING THAT EMBODIES THE
TAGLINE HE CREATED SIX CHANCES
THE TEACHER. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE HE BROUGHT THE FAMOUS
PILGRIM SHIP TO THE OCEAN
INSTITUTE M. AS OF FULL SCALE
REPLICA OF THE SHIP
IMMORTALIZED BY AUTHOR RICHARD
HENRY DANA. IN TWO YEARS BEFORE
THE MAST VISITORS TO THE OCEAN
INSTITUTE IN THE PROGRAM HAVE
BECOME TOP SHIPS SAILORS
RESEARCH SCIENTISTS
OCEANOGRAPHERS AND EXPLORERS.
WELL IMMERSED IN ITS PROGRAMS.
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS CARRIED
OUT ABOARD THE SHIP ARE ONE OF
STAN'S GREATEST LEGACIES SEVEN
EDUCATED MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL KIDS. ABOUT THE OCEAN
AND THE CHALLENGES FACED BY
SEAGOING EXPLORERS WHO
DISCOVERED THE NEW WORLD I KNEW
STAND PERSONALLY AND WORKED
WITH HIM AND HIS INSTITUTE TO
RAISE SUPPORT FOR THESE
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE CREATION
OF A LIVE DINNER THEATER.
ABOARD THE OF THE SHIP I
REMEMBER FONDLY SETTING UP FOOD
FOR ONE OF THE INSTITUTE'S
DINNER EVENTS MY HUSBAND FERRY
GUESTS TO THE PROGRAM FOR THE
EVENT ON OUR BOAT BECAUSE THE
INSTITUTE DID NOT HAVE A DARK
YET. STAND INSPIRED US TO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN THAT OTHERS
BELIEVE OR NOT POSSIBLE.
ANOTHER STANCE THAT SHE REMAINS
WERE STARTING THEIR ANNUAL TALL
SHIPS FESTIVAL IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX THE FUN AND
EDUCATIONAL OF. THE BAND WHICH
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY. THANKS
TO HIS VISION AND HARD WORK
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS AND
VISITORS AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
GAINED A BETTER APPRECIATION.
FOR OCEAN ENVIRONMENT IN A
DESIRE TO MAKE OUR PLANET TO
HELP YOUR PLAYS HE WILL BE
TERRIBLY MISSED BY ALL OF US
WHO WERE INTERVIEWED BY OUR
ASSOCIATION. WITH THIS SPECIAL
MAN STAND CUMMINGS LEAVE THE
TREMENDOUS ENVIRONMENTAL LEGACY
THAT WILL BE FELT FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SIGRID
DAUGHTERS JENNIFER JOHNSON AND
HER LITTLE MOBY MOE MOE D. FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND MANY OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS I ASKED THAT WE
HAD GERMAN STANCE MEMORY AND
SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS
MANY MANY FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
THANK YOU. SENATE RATES THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT FORWARD
AND PLEASE SEND OUR DEEP
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ADVANCE A
INTERNAL MEMORY TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. CENTER ROUTE FOR THE
FLOOR THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
TODAY RISE IN AND TO JOURNAL I
SEE SOON OF DEMARIO JOHNSON A
LOVING FATHER A SON A BROTHER.
ANDA FINE PUBLIC SERVANT
TOMORROW JOHNSON AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWNAS DJ OR D. WAS BORN IN
LAS VEGAS NEVADA ON AUGUST
SECOND NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
HIS PARENTS STEPHEN AND BETTE
WALKER THERE ARE TWO TOMORROW'S
FAMILY SETTLED IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA D. J. ATTENDED WEST
ANGELES CHRISTIAN ACADEMY AND
GRADUATED FROM DAVID STARR
JORDAN HIGH SCHOOL.
INTERNATIONAL BACCALAUREATE
PROGRAM AS VALEDICTORIAN IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
UPON GRADUATION HE ATTENDED
LONG BEACH COLLEGE AND WOULD
LATER ENROLLED IN PENN STATE
MASTERS MATHEMATICS PROGRAM. DJ
WOULD EVENTUALLY PURSUE A
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVING TWELVE YEARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER MOST
RECENTLY WAS EMPLOYED AS A
PAROLE AGENT. GJ LOVED MICHAEL
JORDAN CHICAGO BULLS BARRY
SANDERS DETROIT LIONS POKER AND
IPA'S DJ WAS A JACK OF ALL
TRADES HE WAS GOOD AT
EVERYTHING AND THERE WAS
NOTHING HE COULD NOT LEARN. DJS
HOBBIES WORKING OUT INVESTING
HIS MONEY AND WATCHING IT GROW.
HE ENJOYED TALKING AND GIVING
SOUND FINANCIAL ADVICE TO
OTHERS. DJ UNFORTUNATELY PASSED
AWAY ON JUNE TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF THIRTY SIX YEARS. DJ WAS
A TRUE PUBLIC SERVICE AND
EXCEPTIONAL PERSON. HE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED BY HIS COMMUNITY
HIS FRIENDS AND ESPECIALLY HIS
FAMILY TOMORROW LAMAR JOHNSON
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE DANA
JOHNSON DAUGHTERS GENEVIEVE AND
EVA PARENTS STEPHEN AND BETTE
WALKER SIBLINGS KIMBERLY WALKER
CHRYSLER NJ. MONISHA WILDER AND
JEFF GRANDPARENTS ARLENE
WILLIAMS AND WILLIAM SOUNDS AND
A HOST OF AUNTS UNCLES COUSINS
NIECES NEPHEWS AND FRIENDS WILL
FOREVER KEEP HIS MEMORY ALIVE
AND WELL IN HIS HEART IT IN
THEIR HEARTS. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY INTO
MEMORY OF TOMORROW JOHNSON MAY
HE CONTINUED. TO LIVE ON AND
REST IN PEACE S THE RECORD
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
ELOQUENT TESTIMONY PLEASE SEND
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST SESSION TODAY IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER I
CAN SUGGEST IS CLEAR. MR
PRESIDENT THANKS SO MUCH OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THIS THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY
SIX TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE
AM THANK YOU THANK YOU MATT A
PRETEND THAT MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WE'RE GOING TO BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM
BOTH THAT'S RIGHT WERE GERMAN
HEY. BECAUSE OF A LONG SESSION
VIRGINIA RIGHT NOW OUR BODY AND
THERE WE GO. SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA BE A JOURNEY RIGHT NOW
HAVE A GREAT EVENING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH.